Hello, everyone, and before today's show, I have incredibly exciting news for you about a live show. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be at the South Bank to do something that we have not done before. So you will be the first people to hear it. We are telling the story of what is the ultimate Victorian adventure. The date is 1868. The location is Abyss. And the Emperor of Abyssinia has been writing letters to Queen Victoria, who rather rudely has not replied to them. So the Emperor of Abyssinia, annoyed about this, has kidnapped a number of British subjects.
大家好，在今天的节目开始之前，我有一个关于现场演出的激动人心的消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将在南岸艺术中心做一件我们从未做过的事情。所以你们将是第一批听到这个消息的人。我们将讲述一个终极维多利亚时代的冒险故事。时间是1868年。地点是阿比西尼亚。阿比西尼亚皇帝一直在给维多利亚女王写信，但女王非常粗鲁地没有回复。因此，对此感到恼火的阿比西尼亚皇帝绑架了许多英国臣民。
In response, Britain sends an expedition to rescue the captives. And it is no exaggeration to say, it is massive. On this expedition, 13,000 soldiers, 40,000 animals, including 44 elephants, and the British even put down a railway line to transport everything. It's an incredible story full of jaw-dropping events, ludicrous characters, lots of moustaches, lots of general Victorian shenanigans. and as I say, it is the first time that we have ever done it on The Rest is History. I don't want to blow our trumpet, but I think it's going to be an absolute Restless History classic. So if you want to get a ticket for the ultimate Victorian adventure at the South Bank in London, on Friday the 4th of September, you know where to go.
作为回应，英国派遣了一支远征军去营救人质。毫不夸张地说，这支队伍规模极其庞大。在这支远征军中，有13000名士兵，40000头动物，包括44头大象，英国人甚至铺设了一条铁路线来运输所有物资。这是一个令人难以置信的故事，充满了令人瞠目结舌的事件、荒谬的人物、大量的胡须，以及各种典型的维多利亚时代的闹剧。正如我所说，这是我们第一次在《历史的余味》节目中这样做。我不想自吹自擂，但我认为这将是《历史的余味》的绝对经典。所以，如果你想在9月4日星期五去伦敦南岸艺术中心观看这场终极维多利亚时代的冒险，你知道该去哪里买票。
The Rest is History.com. Drake, he was a Devon Man, and ruled the day. Devon sees. Captain, are those sleeping there below? Roving though his death fell, he went with heart at ease, a dreaming all the time a Plymouth Ho. Take my drum to England, hang it by the shore, strike it when your powders running low. If the darn sight Devon, I'll quit the port of heaven, and drum them up the channel as we drummed them long ago. So that is Drake's drum, Tom Holland's favorite poet, Sir Henry Newbolt, and it was written in 1897, the high point of late Victorian patriotism, the high point of faith in the British Empire, and indeed in the Royal Navy. But it's a point in Britain's history that age, 1890s, when people are beginning to get a little bit worried that the next century, the 20th century might not be as good as the 19th.
The Rest is History.com。德雷克，他是德文郡人，统治着那一天。德文郡的大海。船长，那些睡在下面的人是谁？尽管他死得凄惨，但他漫游时心安理得，一直梦想着普利茅斯。把我的鼓带回英国，挂在岸边，当你的火药快用完时就敲响它。如果德文郡有难，我会离开天堂的港口，像我们很久以前那样，敲着鼓穿过海峡。这就是德雷克的鼓，汤姆·霍兰最喜欢的诗人亨利·纽博尔特爵士的作品，写于1897年，那是维多利亚时代晚期爱国主义的巅峰，是对大英帝国乃至皇家海军信仰的巅峰。但那是英国历史上的一个时刻，那个时代，19世纪90年代，人们开始有点担心下一个世纪，即20世纪，可能不会像19世纪那么好。
And so they're looking for reassurance. They're worried that the foundations of the British Empire are crumbling. and they're looking for reassurance back to the glory days of the Virgin Queen and the origins of English sea power. And in particular, they're looking back to the great maritime hero of the Elizabethan age, probably the greatest English hero between Henry V and Horatio Nelson, and that is Sir Francis Drake. So Nelson had beaten the French. Sir Francis Drake was famous, was celebrated in endless storybooks and textbooks for children, as the man who had seen off the Spanish, the dons as they're called, specifically in the Spanish Armada of 1588.
所以他们正在寻找安慰。他们担心大英帝国的根基正在瓦解。他们正在寻找回到童贞女王时代的辉煌日子和英国海上力量起源的安慰。特别是，他们回望伊丽莎白时代伟大的海上英雄，可能是亨利五世和霍雷肖·纳尔逊之间最伟大的英国英雄，那就是弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。所以纳尔逊打败了法国人。弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士很有名，在无数儿童故事书和教科书中被赞颂为击退西班牙人（即所谓的“唐”）的人，特别是在1588年的西班牙无敌舰队之战中。
But Tom, there's more to him than that, isn't there? Because he was also the great English explorer. At the time, the only man in history who had set off to circumnavigate the world and had been in command of the expedition from the very start of it to the end. So he'd gone up the coast of California, he'd almost gone to Canada. And in fact, in San Francisco, there is still, well, Well, there is St. Francis Drake Boulevard, there's Drake's Bay. It's brilliant that in San Francisco, which you would think of as very woke.
但是汤姆，他不仅仅是那样，对吧？因为他也是伟大的英国探险家。当时，他是历史上唯一一个出发环游世界，并从头到尾指挥这次远征的人。所以他曾沿着加利福尼亚海岸航行，几乎到达了加拿大。事实上，在旧金山，仍然有，嗯，有弗朗西斯·德雷克大道，有德雷克湾。在旧金山，这个你认为非常“觉醒”的地方，人们竟然热爱弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士，这真是太棒了。
They love Sir Francis Drake. Actually, we might touch on this in second. But when he died, he died at sea. He died off the coast of Panama, and he was consigned to the waters. So the poem says, slung between the round shot in Nambred Dios Bay. And the story goes, said the myth, which is celebrated by this poem, is that in Britain's hour of need, rather like King Arthur, he will return, and you will hear the beating of Drake's ghostly drum. That's why the poem is called Drake's Drum.
他们热爱弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。其实，我们稍后可能会谈到这一点。但他去世时，是在海上。他在巴拿马海岸外去世，被安葬在水中。所以诗中说，在诺姆布雷德迪奥斯湾的圆弹之间。故事是这样说的，神话是这样说的，这首诗所赞颂的是，在英国需要的时候，就像亚瑟王一样，他会回来，你会听到德雷克幽灵般的鼓声。这就是为什么这首诗被称为《德雷克的鼓》。
And supposedly, we've done Trafalgar twice, and yet weirdly we forgot to mention this, that before the Battle of Trafalgar, as Nelson and Collingwood and the victory and the royal sovereign, are sailing into action against the French. And the Don's, of course. And the Spanish, of course. Yeah, you're right. they hear the beating of Drake's drum. Also, in the First World War, when we were fighting the Kaiser, Drake's drum again, and no doubt, I mean, I don't hear much about this, but people should talk about this, more Falklands veterans, because I bet they heard Drake's drum before the Battle of Goose Green or some such.
据推测，我们已经两次经历特拉法尔加海战，但奇怪的是我们忘了提到这一点，在特拉法尔加海战之前，当纳尔逊和科林伍德以及“胜利号”和“皇家君主号”航行去对抗法国人时。当然还有那些“唐”。当然还有西班牙人。是的，你说得对。他们听到了德雷克的鼓声。此外，在第一次世界大战中，当我们与德皇作战时，德雷克的鼓声再次响起，毫无疑问，我的意思是，我没有听到太多关于这个的消息，但人们应该更多地谈论这一点，福克兰群岛的退伍军人，因为我敢打赌，他们在鹅绿战役或类似的战斗之前听到了德雷克的鼓声。
Well, it's supposed to have rung out during the Battle of Britain over the channel. Yeah. But the one that people always talk about is when the German high fleet surrendered at the end of the First World War and they sailed into Scapa Flow. an orkney. Then Drake's drum is supposed to have sounded. People looked around and say, where is this drumbeat coming from? And obviously it was coming from heaven. And yet there are some people, aren't there, who questioned Sir Francis Drake. Yes. So there are definitely people who condemn him as a bad guy, because as we will be seeing, as well as rushing around circumnavigating the globe and defeating the Spanish, he began his life as a person. He began his life as
嗯，据说在海峡上空的“不列颠战役”期间，鼓声也响起了。是的。但人们总是谈论的是第一次世界大战结束时，德国公海舰队投降并驶入奥克尼群岛的斯卡帕湾时。那时德雷克的鼓声应该也响起了。人们环顾四周说，这鼓声是从哪里来的？显然它来自天堂。然而，有些人，不是吗，质疑弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。是的。所以确实有人谴责他是个坏人，因为正如我们将要看到的，除了环游世界和击败西班牙人之外，他开始他的生活时是一个人。他开始他的生活时是
participant in the slave trade. And because of that, there are stretches of Sir Francis Drake Boulevard, which is still called Sir Francis Drake Boulevard, but there are other stretches that have been renamed. And they've been in bits of it. I mean, that's so half-hearted. Yeah, I think, because it had to be, there were kind of local people who had to vote on it. I think that's the reason. Okay. And also there was a Sir Francis Drake Hotel in San Francisco, and this is now apparently been renamed the Beacon Grand. That's a terrible name. And just as there is, there is, this kind of centuries-old tradition of admiration for Drake. He's been one of the the great heroes of English history. So also have there been centuries of people really,
奴隶贸易的参与者。正因为如此，弗朗西斯·德雷克大道的一些路段仍然叫弗朗西斯·德雷克大道，但其他路段已经被重新命名了。他们改了一部分。我的意思是，这太敷衍了。是的，我想，因为必须这样做，有一些当地人不得不投票决定。我想这就是原因。好的。而且旧金山还有一家弗朗西斯·德雷克酒店，现在显然已经更名为“灯塔大酒店”。那名字太糟糕了。就像有这种对德雷克长达几个世纪的钦佩传统一样。他一直是英国历史上最伟大的英雄之一。同样也有几个世纪以来人们真的，
really loathing him. And the people who really loathe him are, of course, the dons, the Spaniards, because I guess one country's free-booting sea dog is another country's dangerous pirate. And in the 16th century, so the period of the Tudor Cold War, the theme of this series, Drake became the single most detested figure in Spain, and it helped that his name El Drake in Spanish meant the dragon. And to this day, in Spain, he plays the role of a kind of bogeyman. The kind of the mirror image of Drake's status as a hero in England is this notion of a kind of predatory, piratical monster in Spain. Well, do you know, I mentioned the Falklands, in the Falklands War, the Argentine press typically referred to the
真的厌恶他。而真正厌恶他的人，当然是那些“唐”，即西班牙人，因为我想一个国家的自由掠夺海盗是另一个国家的危险海盗。在16世纪，也就是本系列的主题——都铎冷战时期，德雷克成为了西班牙最令人憎恶的人物，他的名字在西班牙语中意为“龙”（El Drake），这也有影响。直到今天，在西班牙，他扮演着一种“妖怪”的角色。德雷克在英国作为英雄的地位的镜像，就是他在西班牙作为一种掠夺性的海盗怪物的形象。嗯，你知道吗，我提到了福克兰群岛，在福克兰群岛战争中，阿根廷媒体通常称
British as pirates. And they did, you know, there are Argentine magazines where they will mock up Margaret Thatcher as Sir Francis Drake. And they will say deliberate explicitly, she's the heir of this particular man and all Englishmen are in thrall to this bloke, who's an absolutely terrible man, one of the worst villains in history. Yeah. And I think that this points to the kind of incredibly outsized role that he played in the great drama of the series, which is the Cold War between England and Spain between Protestant world and the Catholic world, and of course, between Elizabeth the First, the Virgin Queen of England and Philip the second, the most powerful man on the face of the planet, the King of Spain. The two previous episodes that we've done in this series,
英国人为海盗。他们确实，你知道，有阿根廷杂志把玛格丽特·撒切尔戏称为弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。他们会明确地说，她是这个人的继承人，所有英国人都被这个家伙所奴役，他是一个绝对糟糕的人，历史上最坏的恶棍之一。是的。我认为这指出了他在本系列的大戏中扮演的极其巨大的角色，即英国与西班牙之间、新教世界与天主教世界之间，当然还有伊丽莎白一世（英国童贞女王）与菲利普二世（地球上最有权势的人，西班牙国王）之间的冷战。我们在本系列中制作的前两集，
we were operating pretty much in the shadows. So it was a world of spy chiefs, of double agents, of undercover Jesuits and priest hunters. But in this episode, we are going to be following Drake on the high seas to the Indies, to the Spanish main, and then ultimately around the world. And he is, I think, kind of unlike the Jesuits that we talked about in the previous episode, or even indeed Walsingham and Cecil, the great spy chiefs. He is a massive lad. But he is also, I think, a bit of a rogue. And definitely, whether you love him or hate him, he is incredibly charismatic because he rises
我们基本上是在阴影中运作。所以那是一个间谍头目、双重间谍、卧底耶稣会士和猎杀牧师者的世界。但在这一集中，我们将跟随德雷克在公海上航行，前往西印度群岛，前往西班牙主港，最后环游世界。我认为，他与我们在上一集中谈到的耶稣会士，甚至与沃尔辛厄姆和塞西尔这些伟大的间谍头目不同。他是一个了不起的家伙。但我认为他也有点流氓。而且毫无疑问，无论你爱他还是恨他，他都非常有魅力，因为他从
from nowhere to become the most talked about man, not just in England, but across Europe. He almost single-handedly gives the English what they did not previously have, which is the self-confidence to think of England as possibly becoming the mistress of the seas. And absolutely, as we will be seeing, he began his career as a slaver, but he was also the first English commander in this country's history to ally himself to a black military power. Interesting. So he's a man of complications and ambivalences. A man of contradictions.
无名小卒崛起，成为不仅在英国，而且在整个欧洲谈论最多的人。他几乎凭一己之力给了英国人他们以前所没有的东西，那就是认为英国有可能成为海上霸主的自信。当然，正如我们将要看到的，他以奴隶贩子的身份开始了他的职业生涯，但他也是这个国家历史上第一个与黑人军事力量结盟的英国指挥官。有趣。所以他是一个复杂且矛盾的人。一个充满矛盾的人。
A man of contradictions. And a remarkable figure. And it's a remarkable story. And it begins, as Sir Henry Newbolt in that poem implies in Devon, Francis Drake was a Devon man. And he was born around 1540. we don't know the precise date at Crowndale Farm outside the town of Tavistock in Devon. And he's the grandson of a yeoman farmer.
一个充满矛盾的人。一个非凡的人物。这是一个非凡的故事。正如亨利·纽博尔特爵士在那首诗中所暗示的那样，它始于德文郡，弗朗西斯·德雷克是一个德文郡人。他出生于1540年左右，我们不知道确切日期，出生在德文郡塔维斯托克镇外的克朗代尔农场。他是自耕农的孙子。
And he's not even the son of that yeoman farmer's first son. So he's the son of a second son. And to be the son of a second son is never a good start in life. And this second son, Edmund Drake, so Francis's dad, he's kind of weird mix of intense religiosity and outright criminality. So in 1548, Edmund Drake was indicted for stealing a horse and for mugging a traveler on the Queen's Highway for his purse. So he's in trouble with the law. And then in 1549, so that's the following year while he's trying to keep his kind of legal
他甚至不是那个自耕农长子的儿子。所以他是次子的儿子。作为次子的儿子在生活中从来都不是一个好的开始。这个次子，埃德蒙·德雷克，也就是弗朗西斯的父亲，他是一种强烈的宗教信仰和彻底的犯罪行为的奇怪混合体。所以1548年，埃德蒙·德雷克因偷马和在女王公路上抢劫旅行者的钱包而被起诉。所以他惹上了法律麻烦。然后在1549年，也就是第二年，当他试图保持他的法律
problems at bay, he's embroiled in the outbreak of some very violent sectarian conflict. And this is an anti-protestant uprising in Devon and Cornwall kind of protesting against changes to the prayer book and all of that. And Edmund Drake, who is already kind of in trouble with the law, thinks, well, I don't want to be strung up by angry Catholics. So I'm going to scarper. And so he escapes both the law and Catholic mobs by heading to the opposite end of Southern England to Kent. And there he reinvents himself as a preacher man, as a man of God, totally casting a veil over his career as a criminal. And the young Francis grows up with the consciousness, obviously, of his father as a man of the gospel,
问题不被发现时，他卷入了一场非常暴力的宗派冲突的爆发。这是一场在德文郡和康沃尔郡爆发的反新教起义，抗议对祈祷书的修改等等。已经惹上法律麻烦的埃德蒙·德雷克心想，好吧，我不想被愤怒的天主教徒吊死。所以我得溜走。于是他逃离了法律和天主教暴徒，前往英格兰南部的另一端——肯特郡。在那里，他把自己重塑为一个传教士，一个上帝的仆人，完全掩盖了他作为罪犯的职业生涯。年轻的弗朗西斯在成长过程中，显然意识到他的父亲是一个福音传道者，
preaching to public congregations. Francis grows up absolutely stamped by his father's religious convictions, which we have no reason to doubt. You know, they're very devoutly held. And as an adult, Drake's Protestantism will be very fiery, very unconstitutional. uncompromising, very passionately held. So to quote very much friend of the show, John Sugden. Wow. Great to have him back on the show. Author of the two-volume biography of Nelson, which we both, we drew on a lot for our series on Nelson. He said of Drake that his profound
向公众集会布道。弗朗西斯在成长过程中完全被他父亲的宗教信仰所打下烙印，我们没有理由怀疑这一点。你知道，这些信仰是非常虔诚地持有的。作为成年人，德雷克的基督教新教信仰将是非常炽热的、非常不妥协的、非常热烈地持有的。所以引用节目非常好的朋友约翰·萨格登的话。哇。很高兴他回到节目中。他是纳尔逊两卷本传记的作者，我们两人在制作纳尔逊系列节目时大量借鉴了这本书。他评价德雷克说，他深刻的
faith was arguably his most salient characteristic, and it provided the mainspring of his tempestuous career. And I think that's right. Drake has an incredible appetite for adventure, but that adventure is always in the cause of his understanding of the gospel. And so like a lot of the figures that we've been talking about in this series, William Cecil, who becomes Lord Burley or Francis Walsingham, Drake grows up a very, very committed anti-papist. You know, he is opposed to everything that smacks of the Pope's rule. And that may be even more important to him than the sense he has of himself
信仰可以说是他最显著的特征，它提供了他那动荡职业生涯的动力。我认为这是对的。德雷克对冒险有着难以置信的渴望，但那种冒险总是为了他所理解的福音事业。所以就像我们在本系列中谈到的许多人物一样，威廉·塞西尔（后来成为伯利勋爵）或弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆，德雷克成长为一个非常、非常坚定的反教皇主义者。你知道，他反对任何带有教皇统治色彩的东西。这对他来说可能比他作为
as a committed enemy of Spain. I mean, I think that the hostility to Spain and to the fact that, the Pope alight in Drake, but probably it's hostility to the Pope that is the real kind of motivation for him. Yeah. And the other great influence that Drake's father has on him is that he apprentices the young Francis to a captain who sails the Medway and occasionally crosses from the Thames Estuary over to Flanders and over to northern France. And the captain is an excellent teacher and the young Francis proves to be a really excellent student to the degree that when this captain dies, he leaves his ship to the young Francis, to his apprentice, which I think is clear evidence
西班牙的坚定敌人的自我认知更为重要。我的意思是，我认为对西班牙的敌意，以及教皇在德雷克身上点燃的敌意，但可能对教皇的敌意才是他真正的动力。是的。德雷克的父亲对他的另一个巨大影响是，他让年轻的弗朗西斯去当学徒，跟随一位在梅德韦河航行，偶尔从泰晤士河口横渡到佛兰德斯和法国北部的船长。这位船长是一位出色的老师，年轻的弗朗西斯被证明是一个非常出色的学生，以至于当这位船长去世时，他把他的船留给了年轻的弗朗西斯，留给了他的学徒，我认为这清楚地证明了
as to how much this captain had grown to admire Francis, you know, the sense that he has that this is a young lad who is an absolute natural on the sea. And so when the young Francis Drake, as a young man, returns from Kent to Devon, he is very well set for a career at sea. Yeah. And this is a time when Devon, which is the part of southwest England, that sticks out into the sea towards the Atlantic, this is a period when people in Devon are starting to wake up to the opportunities that the Atlantic might provide them in a way that they hadn't previously done. And he has got, I mean, he's gotten in because he's got a very well-connected cousin, hasn't he, or possibly a second cousin, who is another of the great names of the golden age of Elizabethan
这位船长是多么钦佩弗朗西斯，你知道，他感觉到这是一个在海上绝对有天赋的年轻人。所以当年轻的弗朗西斯·德雷克作为一个年轻人从肯特回到德文郡时，他已经为海上职业生涯做好了充分准备。是的。这是一个德文郡（英格兰西南部伸向大西洋的部分）的人们开始意识到大西洋可能为他们提供机会的时期，这种方式是他们以前从未有过的。而且他有一个，我的意思是，他有一个关系很好的表亲，不是吗，或者可能是堂兄弟，他是伊丽莎白时代黄金时代伟大的名字之一
sea-doggery. Yeah. And that is John Hawkins. So John Hawkins, he is the son of a merchant from the West Country, right? And this is where we get into, we start to get into the issue of the slave trade. Because am I not right thinking that John Hawkins' father had been involved in the slave trade. Yes. And the slave trade by this point is absolutely fundamental to the functioning of Spain's Atlantic economy. Yeah.
海盗。是的。那就是约翰·霍金斯。所以约翰·霍金斯，他是来自西部的商人的儿子，对吧？这就是我们进入，我们开始进入奴隶贸易问题的地方。因为我没记错的话，约翰·霍金斯的父亲也参与了奴隶贸易。是的。而奴隶贸易在这一点上对西班牙大西洋经济的运作绝对是根本性的。是的。
You know, in the way that, I don't know, kind of rare metals are to the functioning of the modern economy. And in both case, of course, the process is incredibly brutal, exploitative inhuman. But for Hawkins, ultimately, it's business. I mean, we've been drawing La Caree comparisons throughout this series. Maybe Hawkins is a kind of very Protestant Richard Roper from the night manager. Oh, yeah, the arms dealer. And he is a guy who essentially wants the gate crash, the Spanish and the Portuguese control. of the Atlantic trade routes. So Hawkins is part of a breed of Devon seamen who are
你知道，就像，我不知道，某种稀有金属对现代经济运作的重要性一样。当然，在这两种情况下，这个过程都是极其残酷、剥削性和不人道的。但对霍金斯来说，归根结底，这是生意。在这个系列中，我们一直在进行勒卡雷式的比较，也许霍金斯就像《夜班经理》中那个非常新教的理查德·罗珀。哦，是的，那个军火商。他是一个本质上想要闯入西班牙和葡萄牙控制的大西洋贸易路线的人。所以霍金斯是德文郡海员中的一员，他们
realizing that there are enormous opportunities out there and that the sailors of the Iberian Peninsula have been hoarding it for themselves. And they've been awarded these oceans by the Pope, but as Protestants, you know, the ship owners of Devon don't care about that. So they are out to try and get a bit of the loop for themselves. And so it is in 1562 that John Hawkins had embarked on the first slaving voyage in English history, kind of very dark moment in our island story. And it proves incredibly lucrative, so much so that investors then start piling in. And Hawkins is able to use this investment to fund further slaving expeditions. And this is where the young Francis Drake comes in. So he might have sailed on the first two
意识到外面有巨大的机会，而伊比利亚半岛的水手们一直把这些机会据为己有。教皇把这些海洋授予了他们，但作为新教徒，你知道，德文郡的船主们并不在乎这一点。所以他们想尝试从中分一杯羹。因此，1562年，约翰·霍金斯开始了英国历史上第一次奴隶航行，这是我们岛屿故事中非常黑暗的时刻。事实证明这非常有利可图，以至于投资者开始蜂拥而至。霍金斯能够利用这笔投资资助进一步的奴隶远征。这就是年轻的弗朗西斯·德雷克介入的地方。所以他可能在霍金斯的前两次
of Hawkins' slaving expeditions as a common seaman. But he definitely, accompanies Hawkins on his third slaving expedition. And this leaves Plymouth in Devon in 1567. And the vibe on board, it's a kind of ferocious blend of Protestantism, of patriotism, and of sheer naked greed. And I think Drake bites into all those kind of characteristics. And he does very well. So Hawkins captures a Portuguese ship on the course of this this slaving expedition, and he gives it to the young Francis to command. So as far as we know, that is Drake's first command. And then in due cause, Drake does so well, in charge of this Portuguese ship, that Hawkins gives Drake the command of one of his own ships, the Judith.
奴隶远征中作为普通水手航行。但他肯定陪同霍金斯进行了第三次奴隶远征。这于1567年离开德文郡的普利茅斯。船上的氛围是一种新教、爱国主义和赤裸裸的贪婪的凶猛混合体。我认为德雷克吸收了所有这些特征。他做得很好。所以霍金斯在这次奴隶远征中俘获了一艘葡萄牙船，他把它交给了年轻的弗朗西斯指挥。据我们所知，那是德雷克的第一次指挥。后来，德雷克在指挥这艘葡萄牙船时表现出色，霍金斯把自己的船之一“朱迪思号”交给了德雷克指挥。
So clearly, Hawkins can see in the young Francis Drake what that captain had seen who'd given him the ship. This is a guy who is entirely suited to command on the sea. So everything's looking good for Drake. But a year after he's left Plymouth, so September 1568, things start to go wrong, don't there? And this is basically the issue that you always have is you're at the mercy of the elements. And Hawkinson's fleet are in the Caribbean. They think they are trading. The Spanish would say they're smuggling.
显然，霍金斯在年轻的弗朗西斯·德雷克身上看到了那位把船交给他的船长所看到的东西。这是一个完全适合在海上指挥的人。所以德雷克的一切看起来都很好。但在他离开普利茅斯一年后，即1568年9月，事情开始出错了，不是吗？这基本上是你总是面临的问题，那就是你受制于自然因素。霍金斯的船队在加勒比海。他们认为他们在贸易。西班牙人会说他们在走私。
And they're massively blown off course, aren't they? I mean, they're blown basically to Vera Cruz, which is modern-day Mexico. And I think this featured in a series about the fall of the Aztecs, didn't it? Is exactly where they go? Yeah, where Cortez met the emissaries from Montezuma and there was all sort of great banter with exchanging gifts and firing cannons and things. All of that, yes. So this has been called by the Spanish San Juan de Ulua. And Alua apparently derives from the local name for the Aztecs.
他们被吹离了航线，不是吗？我的意思是，他们基本上被吹到了维拉克鲁斯，也就是现代的墨西哥。我想这在关于阿兹特克帝国灭亡的系列节目中出现过，对吧？正是他们去的地方？是的，科尔特斯在那里会见了蒙特祖马的使者，那里有各种各样的精彩互动，交换礼物、发射大炮等等。所有这些，是的。这被西班牙人称为圣胡安·德乌卢阿。而“乌卢阿”显然源自当地对阿兹特克人的称呼。
So Hawkins and Drake and the slaving expedition, you know, they've sold all the slaves by now and they've got their money and they're ready to go back home to England. But they've been blown off course. And they have arrived at the place where the Spanish adventure on the same. Spanish main. So that's the kind of the mainland of America. It's where it began. But it is terrible timing because while they're making their repairs, the Spanish viceroy of Mexico turns up with a massive fleet, including two huge warships, completely bristling with cannon. And the English flotilla is completely dwarfed by it. So Hawkins desperately tries to kind of sign a truce with the Spanish, you know, concealing the fact that he's basically been trespassing in Spanish waters.
所以霍金斯和德雷克以及奴隶远征队，你知道，他们现在已经卖掉了所有的奴隶，拿到了钱，准备回家去英国。但他们被吹离了航线。他们到达了西班牙人在同一地方冒险的地方。西班牙主港。所以那是美国的大陆。那是它开始的地方。但时机太糟糕了，因为当他们进行维修时，墨西哥的西班牙总督带着一支庞大的舰队出现了，包括两艘巨大的战舰，上面布满了大炮。英国小舰队完全被它压倒了。所以霍金斯拼命试图与西班牙人签署停战协议，你知道，隐瞒他基本上一直在西班牙水域非法入侵的事实。
And the Spanish sign it, but there's an element of treachery in this, because the Spanish are just kind of preparing to launch a full-scale attack on this intrusive English fatilla. And they justify this on the grounds that the English are pirates and trespassers and criminals, which I guess if you're Spanish, you know, is nothing less than the truth. And the impact of this attack is devastating. So four English ships are sunk. Over 300 English sailors are killed. 114 are taken prisoner.
西班牙人签署了协议，但这其中有一种背叛的成分，因为西班牙人只是准备对这支入侵的英国小舰队发动全面攻击。他们以此为由，认为英国人是海盗、入侵者和罪犯，我想如果你是西班牙人，你知道，这确实是事实。这次袭击的影响是毁灭性的。四艘英国船只被击沉。超过300名英国水手被杀。114人被俘。
Lots of these are sent to the galley. There is one poor guy, a man actually not from England but from Cork in Ireland, who is burnt at the stake. Drake and Hawkins both managed to get away, but their ships have been very badly mauled in this battle. And Hawkins ends up taking a massive financial hit. So all that money that he'd made, slave trading has basically been lost. And the debacle leaves both men, but I think particularly Drake, feeling very badly bruised. And it has a profound impact on the future course of his life. Because Drake is left feeling very humiliated, both by the defeat, the fact that the English
其中许多人被送往桨帆船。有一个可怜的家伙，实际上不是来自英国，而是来自爱尔兰科克，被处以火刑。德雷克和霍金斯都设法逃脱了，但他们的船只在这场战斗中受到了重创。霍金斯最终遭受了巨大的经济打击。所以他通过奴隶贸易赚到的所有钱基本上都损失了。这次惨败让两人，但我认为特别是德雷克，感到非常受伤。这对他的未来生活产生了深远的影响。因为德雷克感到非常羞辱，不仅是因为失败，因为英国人
have been pulverized by the Spanish, but also because he had escaped the battle before Hawkins did. And so there are rumours that he had been guilty of cowardice. And it seems possible that Hawkins himself believe this. And certainly when they return, there's an element of bad blood between the cousins. And I think Drake therefore feels he has massive amounts to prove. And it compounds the sense of anger and outrage that he feels specifically towards the Spanish. And he has a kind of gunslinger in a spaghetti Western resolve to be avenged. Right.
被西班牙人粉碎了，还因为他在霍金斯之前就逃离了战场。所以有传言说他犯了怯懦罪。霍金斯本人似乎也相信这一点。当然，当他们回来时，表兄弟之间有一种不和。我认为德雷克因此觉得他有大量的东西需要证明。这加剧了他对西班牙人的愤怒和愤慨。他有一种意大利西部片中枪手般的复仇决心。对。
You know, he, he wants to go back and take his anger and his frustration and his sense of shame out on the people that he blames for the humiliation that he'd experienced at San Juan de Ulua. So he's returned to, to England, kind of limping in in his battered ship, the early weeks of 1569. And he's obviously hoping that maybe he could appeal to Elizabeth's government that maybe they would kind of rally around, help him out. financially, rally to the cause. But this is never going to happen because Elizabeth is very, very nervous about offending the Spanish. She doesn't want to go to war. She hates war. And essentially, the Spanish are right. I mean, Drake had been operating pretty much as a pirate. And so when Drake finds out that he's not going to get any support from Elizabeth's government for his campaign of reprisal against the Spanish, he takes an amazing course. He thinks,
你知道，他想回去，把他对在圣胡安·德乌卢阿所经历的羞辱的愤怒、挫折感和羞耻感发泄在他所责怪的人身上。所以他在1569年初，开着他那艘破烂的船一瘸一拐地回到了英国。他显然希望也许他能向伊丽莎白的政府求助，也许他们会团结起来，在经济上帮助他，团结在事业周围。但这永远不会发生，因为伊丽莎白非常、非常担心冒犯西班牙人。她不想开战。她讨厌战争。本质上，西班牙人是对的。我的意思是，德雷克基本上一直像海盗一样行事。所以当德雷克发现他不会从伊丽莎白政府那里得到任何支持来对他针对西班牙人的报复行动时，他采取了一个惊人的行动。他想，
okay, well, I will declare war on the Spanish myself. And this might seem like a mad thing to do. But the truth is that Drake is a very, very shrewd and opportunistic operator. And while he was in the Indies, he had been taking very careful note of what he was seeing there. And these observations have led him to a conclusion that no one else, not just in England, but basically anywhere in Europe has quite arrived at. And this is that trying to break the Portuguese monopoly on slave trading, or indeed any of the Portuguese or Spanish monopolies of trading in the Atlantic is a Mug's game. The real money is to be found in piracy, because despite the disaster at San Juan
好吧，那我就自己向西班牙人宣战。这看起来可能是一件疯狂的事情。但事实是，德雷克是一个非常、非常精明和机会主义的经营者。当他在西印度群岛时，他一直在非常仔细地记录他在那里看到的东西。这些观察结果使他得出了一个结论，不仅在英国，而且基本上在欧洲的任何地方，都没有人完全得出过这个结论。这就是试图打破葡萄牙对奴隶贸易的垄断，或者实际上打破葡萄牙或西班牙在大西洋贸易中的任何垄断，都是傻瓜的游戏。真正的钱在于海盗行为，因为尽管圣胡安·德乌卢阿发生了灾难，
de Ulua, Drake has noted that Spain's defenses in the Indies and on the Spanish main, are actually very weak because they are not expecting to be attacked. No one from Europe has actually sailed there with the aim of attacking these ports, these fortresses in the Americas. And so Drake is thinking, well, with boldness and good planning, we could take the Spanish completely by surprise. And if we do that, they have so much treasure coming through. all this kind of silver which is coming up from Peru, all the gold and the other treasure
德雷克已经注意到西班牙在西印度群岛和西班牙主港的防御实际上非常薄弱，因为他们没料到会被攻击。欧洲没有人真正航行到那里，目的是攻击美洲的这些港口和堡垒。所以德雷克心想，好吧，只要有胆量和好的计划，我们就能完全让西班牙人措手不及。如果我们这样做，他们有那么多的财宝运过来。所有这些从秘鲁运上来的白银，所有从墨西哥运来的黄金和其他财宝，
from Mexico, we could just take it. And this is the start of what will become, I guess, the most devastating piracy in English history. We say of piracy, but we would, I mean, all the children's books I used to read about Francis Drake said he was not a pirate. He was a privateer, which is very different. Did he see himself as a pirate? if you had put it to him that he was engaged in piracy?
我们完全可以抢走。这就是我猜将成为英国历史上最具破坏性的海盗行为的开始。我们说是海盗行为，但我们，我的意思是，我过去读过的所有关于弗朗西斯·德雷克的儿童读物都说他不是海盗。他是私掠船长，这非常不同。他把自己看作海盗吗？如果你问他是否从事海盗行为？
Well, to be a privateer, you have to have the sanction of a government to operate. Of course, yeah. And he doesn't have that. He does not have that. So I think at that point, by English as well as by Spanish law, he is operating as a pirate. He would say, I think, that he is operating as a godly Protestant attacking the evil papists. And of course, he is out for revenge. And so he would say, I'm launching raids.
嗯，要成为私掠船长，你必须得到政府的批准才能运作。当然，是的。但他没有那个。他没有那个。所以我认为在那个时候，根据英国和西班牙的法律，他是在作为海盗运作。我想他会说，他是在作为一个虔诚的新教徒攻击邪恶的教皇信徒。当然，他是在寻求复仇。所以他会说，我是在发动突袭。
And these are, they're both raids and reconnaissance missions, his first kind of trips out, out to the Indies. He's basically working out, where should we strike? They are quite lucrative. So when Drake returns to Devon from his first raid in 1571, he has made three times the profit that Hawkins had made on all his slaving trips. So Drake has definitely worked out, yeah, you know, you can get rich with these. But more significantly than that, he's used these raids to kind of sniff around the treasure routes, the shipping lanes that link Spain to the gold and silver of the new world, and which of course are incredibly strategically important to Philip and the operations of his empire, because it's this treasure that is funding his armies in, say, the low countries or Italy or wherever. And Drake has identified the perfect place to attack. It's a weak point that is basically stuffed to the gills with treasure.
这些既是突袭也是侦察任务，他最初几次前往西印度群岛的航行。他基本上是在弄清楚，我们应该在哪里打击？它们相当有利可图。所以当德雷克在1571年从他的第一次突袭回到德文郡时，他赚到的利润是霍金斯所有奴隶航行利润的三倍。所以德雷克绝对弄清楚了，是的，你知道，你可以通过这些致富。但更重要的是，他利用这些突袭来窥探宝藏路线，那些连接西班牙与新世界黄金和白银的航运路线，当然，这些路线对菲利普和他的帝国运作具有极其重要的战略意义，因为正是这些财宝在资助他在低地国家或意大利等地的军队。德雷克已经确定了攻击的完美地点。这是一个基本上塞满了财宝的弱点。
And it's a port on the Caribbean coast of Panama called Nomre de Dios, the name of God. Yeah. So this is where the silver is being brought from Potosi in Bolivia, which we talked about in our final episode on the Incas, didn't we? It's the greatest silver mine ever found, discovered in 1545, and basically for two centuries. it will flood the entire world with silver. An incredible thing. And it's still going.
这是一个位于巴拿马加勒比海岸的港口，叫诺姆布雷德迪奥斯（上帝之名）。是的。所以这就是白银从玻利维亚的波托西运来的地方，我们在关于印加人的最后一集中谈到过，不是吗？这是有史以来发现的最大的银矿，发现于1545年，基本上两个世纪以来，它将用白银淹没整个世界。一件不可思议的事情。而且它还在继续。
You know, the Cerro Rico, I think they call it. Just an unbelievable, I mean, hellish. People used to say the single worst place in human history or one of the worst places. Yeah, hell on earth, isn't it? But producing all of this treasure. I mean, nothing like it in human history has existed before. And so it's brought down to the coast from this great mine, loaded onto ships, and then the ships sail up the coast of South America to Panama.
你知道，他们称之为“塞罗里科”。简直令人难以置信，我的意思是，地狱般。人们过去常说这是人类历史上最糟糕的地方，或者是最糟糕的地方之一。是的，人间地狱，不是吗？但它生产了所有这些财宝。我的意思是，人类历史上以前从未存在过这样的东西。所以它从这个伟大的矿山运到海岸，装上船，然后船沿着南美海岸航行到巴拿马。
It's loaded onto mules and donkeys, and there is a kind of 30-mile mule trail which threads its way through thick forest from Panama on the Pacific coast to Nome de Dios on the Atlantic coast. And at Nome de de Dios, the treasure is loaded onto these vast galleons, these vast transport ships, and then it is taken across the Atlantic to Spain.
它被装上骡子和驴子，有一条30英里的骡道，穿过从太平洋海岸的巴拿马到大西洋海岸的诺姆布雷德迪奥斯的茂密森林。在诺姆布雷德迪奥斯，财宝被装上这些巨大的大帆船，这些巨大的运输船，然后被带过大西洋运往西班牙。
So it is, in a sense, kind of, you know, It's the great treasure house of the world, but it's very, very poorly defended. No real fortifications, very little artillery. And it depends for protection, essentially on the fact that it is very, very isolated, and that people outside Spain up until this point have not thought to look for it. But Drake has sniffed it out. And so by the spring of 1752, He is ready for the big one, a direct attack on Nomre de Dios.
所以从某种意义上说，它是，你知道，它是世界上的大宝库，但它的防御非常、非常薄弱。没有真正的防御工事，几乎没有火炮。它的保护基本上取决于它非常、非常孤立的事实，以及直到这一点，西班牙以外的人还没有想到去寻找它。但德雷克已经嗅到了它。所以到1572年春天，他已经为大行动做好了准备，直接攻击诺姆布雷德迪奥斯。
And this by now, people in Devon and particularly in Plymouth are starting to think, yeah, he's really onto something here. This is very, very exciting. And so Drake has no trouble in raising funds for this expedition, nor does he have any difficulty in finding sailors who want to join him on the trip to the Spanish main. Because his two previous ventures, you know, people have noted the money that he's brought back and the kind of stories of the rich pickings to be had. You know, people are aware of his plan.
到目前为止，德文郡，特别是普利茅斯的人们开始认为，是的，他真的发现了什么。这非常、非常令人兴奋。所以德雷克在为这次远征筹集资金方面没有困难，在寻找愿意加入他前往西班牙主港的水手方面也没有任何困难。因为他之前的两次冒险，你知道，人们已经注意到了他带回来的钱，以及关于可以获得的丰厚收获的故事。你知道，人们意识到他的计划。
And the measure of this is that even John Hawkins, you know, his cousin with whom there was bad blood, even he decides to kind of, you know, mend things up and to sink some money into this expedition. And I think for Hawkins, as for Drake himself, and as with lots of the sailors who are sailing with Drake on this expedition, I mean, it's definitely about profit. There's no question about that.
衡量这一点的是，即使是约翰·霍金斯，你知道，他那个有不和的表亲，甚至他也决定，你知道，修补关系，并向这次远征投入一些资金。我认为对霍金斯来说，就像对德雷克本人一样，以及对许多与德雷克一起参加这次远征的水手来说，我的意思是，这绝对是关于利润。毫无疑问。
They all want to make themselves rich. But I think they do also want vengeance. I think there's a sense in which people in Devon feel that that slaughter at San Juan de Ulua was in some way an insult to them personally. And they, like Drake himself, want their vengeance. And I think that sailors who are joining Drake, when they see him, they feel there is really something special about him. So to see Drake, there's nothing particularly impressive about him physically. He's quite short. I mean, he's stocky, very broad-shouldered, but he's not a kind of giant of a man by any means.
他们都想让自己致富。但我认为他们也确实想要复仇。我认为德文郡的人们有一种感觉，圣胡安·德乌卢阿的那场屠杀在某种程度上是对他们个人的侮辱。他们，像德雷克本人一样，想要复仇。我认为加入德雷克的水手们，当他们看到他时，他们觉得他身上确实有一些特别的东西。所以看到德雷克，他在身体上并没有什么特别令人印象深刻的地方。他相当矮。我的意思是，他身材魁梧，肩膀很宽，但绝不是那种巨人。
He's got this kind of reddish hair, reddish beard. But as I say, he's not physically imposing, but he is very charismatic and he exudes a sense of confidence and authority. And so although his schemes may seem wild, most people in Plymouth think, yeah, he could pull this on. It's worth giving him a go. Right. So 24th of May, 1572, Drake leaves Plymouth. He's got two ships and he's got three kind of IKEA-style pinnasses, which he's planning to... Flat packs.
他有这种红色的头发，红色的胡子。但正如我所说，他在身体上并不引人注目，但他非常有魅力，散发出一种自信和权威感。所以虽然他的计划看起来很疯狂，但普利茅斯的大多数人认为，是的，他能做到。值得让他试一试。对。1572年5月24日，德雷克离开普利茅斯。他有两艘船和三艘宜家风格的小帆船，他计划……平板包装。
Yeah. Flat packs to build when he reaches the West Indies. He's got about 100 men and he's got provisions for around a year. And they reached the Spanish main on the 12th of July. And this is where they assemble the pinnaces. So now they've got five ships. And from this point on, everything about the expedition is like the pirates of the Caribbean. It's so Hollywood, everything that happens from now on.
是的。到达西印度群岛时组装的平板包装。他有大约100人，有大约一年的补给。他们在7月12日到达了西班牙主港。这就是他们组装小帆船的地方。所以现在他们有五艘船了。从这一点开始，远征的一切就像《加勒比海盗》。从现在开始发生的一切都太好莱坞了。
So Drake's first move is to attack Nomre de Dios directly. And the amazing thing is that it almost comes off. So the English fleet sails into the harbour under cover of darkness, and they're aboard rowboats. So they're kind of gliding in. And they take the town completely by surprise. And as a result of this, it seems that they have the treasure house at their mercy. But just as they're about to advance on it and kind of, you know, blow the gates, it starts to rain. And this leaves the English gunpowder sodden.
所以德雷克的第一个举动是直接攻击诺姆布雷德迪奥斯。令人惊奇的是，它几乎成功了。所以英国舰队在夜幕掩护下驶入港口，他们乘坐划艇。所以他们悄悄地滑了进去。他们让城镇完全措手不及。结果，似乎宝库就在他们的掌握之中。但就在他们准备推进并，你知道，炸开大门时，开始下雨了。这让英国人的火药变得湿透了。
And even the strings on their crossbows are kind of left useless. And also in the fighting, Drake has been wounded in the leg and he looks down and suddenly realize that he's losing a lot of blood. And he's kind of, you know, turning a bit faint. And so to quote the record of the expedition that's written up later, his men abandoned a most rich spoil for the present only to preserve their captain's life. Drake is disappointed. You know, he was so close, but so far.
甚至他们弩上的弦也变得毫无用处。而且在战斗中，德雷克的腿部受伤了，他低头一看，突然意识到他正在流很多血。他有点，你知道，变得有点晕厥。所以引用后来写下的远征记录，他的手下放弃了最丰富的战利品，只是为了保住他们船长的性命。德雷克很失望。你知道，他离成功如此之近，却又如此之远。
But he's not unduly downcast because I think he's essentially amazed that the Spanish at Nomredaidos had proved even more useless than he'd been expecting that they would. And so to quote the record, and therefore he advised the governor of, nomri de Dios, to hold open his eyes. For before he departed, if God lent him life and leave, he meant to reap some of their harvest, which they get out of the earth and send into Spain to trouble all the earth. And you can see why he becomes such a hero in England. There's something of Robin Hood there. Yeah. Kind of telling the Sheriff of Nottingham, I'm going to come in and steal all your treasure. Do you think he really did that? Because it would be
但他并没有过度沮丧，因为我认为他基本上很惊讶，诺姆布雷德迪奥斯的西班牙人表现得比他预期的还要无能。所以引用记录，因此他建议诺姆布雷德迪奥斯的总督睁大眼睛。因为在他离开之前，如果上帝借给他生命和许可，他打算收获他们从大地中获取并送往西班牙以困扰整个地球的一些庄稼。你可以看出为什么他成为英国的英雄。那里有罗宾汉的影子。是的。有点像告诉诺丁汉郡长，我要进来偷走你所有的财宝。你认为他真的那样做了吗？因为那将是
foolish, surely, to foreworn this guy. I think he did because he's among other things. He's a master of psychological warfare. Okay. Yeah, he's trolling him. Yeah, exactly. He's building a kind of sense of himself as a menacing figure operating in the shadows who has to be taken seriously. Yeah. And as you say, that kind of trolling is something that makes Drake, even at this stage, before he's really taken any treasure from the Spanish, makes him into a kind of bogey manner, you know, a phantom of the shadows. Well, I mean, not least because he actually does it, right? He actually follows through on his promise. He does. So how does he pull it off, this amazing kind of heist?
愚蠢，当然，去预警这家伙。我想他这么做是因为他除了其他身份外，还是心理战的大师。好吧。是的，他在钓鱼执法。没错，正是如此。他正在塑造一种形象，让自己成为一个在阴影中行动、必须被认真对待的威胁性人物。是的。正如你所说，这种钓鱼行为让德雷克，即使在这个阶段，在他还没从西班牙人那里夺取任何财宝之前，就已经变成了一个类似“妖怪”的人物，你知道，阴影中的幽灵。嗯，我的意思是，不仅仅是因为他真的做到了，对吧？他真的兑现了他的承诺。他确实做到了。那么他是如何完成这次惊人的抢劫的呢？
And the simple answer is, he finds some very unexpected allies. And Drake is introduced to these allies by an African who's been called Diego by the Spanish. He's a slave who had defected to the English during their raid on Nome de Dios. And Drake adopts Diego as a crew member. And the two men get on tremendously well. So Miranda Kaufman, who wrote a great book on black tudors, Diego is one of the 10 black tutors in that book. And the friendship between Drake and Diego seems to have been a very close one. And in fact, in his book, John Sugden points out that in the official narrative of the voyage, the one we've been quoting,
简单的回答是，他找到了一些非常意想不到的盟友。德雷克是被一个被西班牙人称为迭戈的非洲人介绍给这些盟友的。他是一个在英国人袭击诺姆德迪奥斯期间投奔他们的奴隶。德雷克收留了迭戈作为船员。这两个人相处得非常好。米兰达·考夫曼写了一本关于“黑人都铎王朝”的好书，迭戈就是书中提到的10位黑人之一。德雷克和迭戈之间的友谊似乎非常深厚。事实上，约翰·萨格登在他的书中指出，在官方的航行叙述中，也就是我们一直引用的那本，
Diego is mentioned more than any of the other seamen on either ship in Drake's expedition. And he pretty much ends up as kind of Drake's right-hand man because he reveals that in the heights above Panama, there are African outlaws, escaped slaves called Cimarones. And these Cimarronos are very proficient at fighting, and they're very keen for vengeance on the Spanish. So in every way, they're just the kind of guys that Drake wants to make friends with. it's an absolute marriage made in heaven. And for the Spanish, of course, it is an absolute disaster. And as an official in Panama, you know, the Spanish very rapidly become aware of this alliance between the Cimarones and Drake's Englishmen. This league between the English and the Negroes is very detrimental to this kingdom. Because being so familiar with the region and so expert in the
迭戈被提及的次数比德雷克远征队中任何其他船员都要多。他最终几乎成了德雷克的得力助手，因为他透露在巴拿马的高地上，有非洲逃犯，即逃跑的奴隶，被称为西马隆人。这些西马隆人非常擅长战斗，而且非常渴望向西班牙人复仇。所以从各方面来看，他们正是德雷克想要结交的那种人。这简直是天作之合。而对于西班牙人来说，这当然是一场彻底的灾难。正如巴拿马的一位官员所知，西班牙人很快就意识到了西马隆人和德雷克的英国人之间的这种联盟。这种英国人和黑人之间的联盟对这个王国是非常有害的。因为他们对该地区非常熟悉，而且在丛林中非常专业，
bush, the Negroes will show the methods and means to accomplish any evil design they may wish to carry out. And Drake does absolutely have a design because early in 1573, he has brought the news that he's been waiting for. The Spanish treasure fleet has arrived in Nomreda de Dios, ready to pick up a vast consignment of silver that is in Panama on the Pacific side of the Isthmus. And this is about 60 miles away, you know, along this kind of mule trail. And the treasure has been kept there because the Spanish assume, you know, it will be more secure. There's no way that anyone could attack it actually in Panama. But Drake's plan is to ambush the mule train that will be bringing the silver from Panama. And so that February, he goes with the cimarone's up into the heights above the mule train to try and kind of work out the lay of the land.
黑人会展示实现他们可能想要执行的任何邪恶计划的方法和手段。德雷克确实有一个计划，因为在1573年初，他得到了他一直在等待的消息。西班牙宝藏船队已经抵达诺姆德迪奥斯，准备装载一批存放在太平洋一侧巴拿马的巨额白银。这大约有60英里远，你知道，沿着这条骡道。财宝一直存放在那里，因为西班牙人认为，你知道，那里会更安全。在巴拿马，根本没有人能攻击它。但德雷克的计划是伏击那支将从巴拿马运送白银的骡队。所以那年二月，他带着西马隆人进入骡道上方的高地，试图摸清地形。
And after four days in the wild, they come to a great tree standing on a very high hill. And the Cimarones have cut steps into the side of the trunk of the tree. And at the top of the tree, there's a kind of treehouse, a viewing platform. And Drake climbs up the steps and he gets to this viewing platform. And from it, he is able to see the Pacific as well as the Atlantic. So it's in the Keats poem. He and all his men are kind of looking at each other. Unbelievable.
在野外待了四天后，他们来到了一座高山上的一棵大树前。西马隆人在树干一侧刻了台阶。在树顶上，有一个类似树屋的观景平台。德雷克爬上台阶，到达了这个观景平台。从那里，他既能看到太平洋，也能看到大西洋。这就像济慈的诗里写的那样。他和他的所有船员都在面面相觑。难以置信。
And Drake, when he sees the Pacific, something that no Englishman has ever seen before. to quote the record, he besought almighty God of his goodness to give him life and leave to sail once in an English ship in that sea. I mean, it's very Drake. Yeah, and actually it's a, I was about to ask,
当德雷克看到太平洋时，这是以前从未有任何英国人见过的景象。引用记录的话说，他祈求全能的上帝施恩，让他有生之年能有机会乘坐一艘英国船只在那片海域航行。我的意思是，这非常德雷克。是的，实际上，我正要问，
is he the first Englishman to see the Pacific? Of course, loads of Spaniards have seen it, but it's a sign of how England has been locked out of so far the kind of exploration of the new world. And everyone in Europe. Only the Spanish really have seen it.
他是第一个看到太平洋的英国人吗？当然，很多西班牙人都见过，但这标志着英国迄今为止是如何被排除在新世界的探索之外的。欧洲的每个人都是如此。只有西班牙人真正见过它。
Yeah. And it's very Drake that, you know, the moment he sees this, kind of unknown vastness of the ocean, he thinks, oh, I want to go there. You know, I want to, I want to explore it. But of course, his immediate concern is this mule train, Loden Dan, with treasure. And so a few days later, they see it approaching and they lie in ambush. But unfortunately, one of Drake's men has got drunk and he launches the ambush too early and gives the game
是的。这非常德雷克，你知道，当他看到这片未知的浩瀚海洋时，他想，哦，我想去那里。你知道，我想去探索它。但当然，他最关心的是那支装满财宝的骡队。几天后，他们看到它靠近了，于是他们设下埋伏。但不幸的是，德雷克的一个手下喝醉了，他过早地发动了伏击，暴露了目标。
away. Drake still doesn't despair. He goes under cover. He lets a month or so pass so that the Spanish will think he's given up and gone home. And then on the 1st of April, he launches a second ambush, and this one is a resounding success. There are no kind of drunks spoiling the surprise. And they take 30 tonnes of gold and silver. And that is such a hall that half of it actually has to be buried because it's too heavy to be transported. And even after the treasure has been shared out among Drake's allies, including the Cimarronos, it's a completely spectacular Hall. And when Drake reaches Plymouth, he does so, to quote, Sugden, with wealth, few Englishmen could have amassed in a lifetime. You know, it is basically the greatest robbery in the whole
德雷克并没有绝望。他转入地下。他让时间过去了一个月左右，这样西班牙人就会以为他已经放弃并回家了。然后在4月1日，他发动了第二次伏击，这次取得了巨大的成功。没有醉汉破坏惊喜。他们夺取了30吨黄金和白银。这笔战利品多到一半不得不被埋掉，因为太重了，无法运输。即使在财宝分给德雷克的盟友（包括西马隆人）之后，这仍然是一个极其壮观的收获。当德雷克到达普利茅斯时，引用萨格登的话说，他带着少数英国人一生中能积累的财富回来了。你知道，这基本上是英国历史上到目前为止最伟大的抢劫案，因为未来还会有更多。我认为，那种未来还会有更多的感觉，基本上，你知道，我们只是触及了表面。财宝很棒。但我认为更重要的是德雷克带回来的这种战略情报，关于财宝路线的细节，这些路线有多脆弱，特别是太平洋中存在的机会，西班牙人根本没料到会被突袭。特别是与西马隆人的这种联盟。所以，正如我们所说，这是英国船长与黑人势力建立的第一个联盟。一位被英国人俘虏的西班牙人报告说，他曾听弗朗西斯船长说，
of English history up until this point, because more will be to come. And I think the, that sense that there is more to come, that basically, you know, we've just scratched the surface. The treasure is brilliant. But I think what is even more significance is this kind of strategic, intelligence that Drake brings back with him, the details of the treasure routes, of how vulnerable these treasure routes are, and specifically the opportunities to be had in the Pacific, where the Spanish do not expect to be surprised. And in particular, there is this alliance with the Cimarone. So, as we said, it's the first alliance ever made by a British captain with a black power. And a Spaniard taken prisoner by the English reported of Drake, he had heard Captain Francis say
他爱他们，他称赞他们，每天都询问他们是否平安。你可以想象他会这样做，因为没有西马隆人，我不认为德雷克能够完成这个惊人的骗局。所以，说一个非常显而易见的事实，没有任何迹象表明德雷克有偏见，或者德雷克会成为我们现在所说的种族主义者。我的意思是，并不是说他们在16世纪有种族主义的概念。我认为德雷克，你知道，如果他能为了利润出卖黑人，他会那样做；如果他能为了利润与黑人结盟，他也会那样做。
that he loved them and he spoke well of them and every day he asked if they were in peace. And you could well imagine that he would because without the Cimarones, I don't think Drake would have been able to pull this in tremendous scam. So just to make a very obvious point, there's absolutely no suggestion whatsoever that Drake is prejudiced, that Drake would be what we would now call racist. I mean, not that they have the concept, I suppose, of racism in the 16th century. I think Drake, you know, if he can sell black people for profit, he'll do that. and if he can ally himself with black people for profit, he'll do that as well.
对。那是生意。我认为德雷克的关键词是利润。是利润，但也显然是上帝指引了他，你知道，向他展示了这些机会。所以也有虔诚的成分。正是这种贪婪与清教主义的融合，才是德雷克的全部。我认为还有对冒险本身的喜爱。我的意思是，我认为这真的非常非常重要。
Right. That's business. Key word there is prophets, I think, for Drake. It's profit, but also clearly God has sent him in the, you know, has shown him these opportunities. So there's an element of godliness as well. And it's that fusion of greed and puritanism that is what Drake is all about. And I think a love of adventure for its own sake. I mean, I think that is really, really important.
我认为这就是为什么德雷克变得如此受人爱戴和钦佩，因为人们，甚至在某种程度上包括西班牙人，都对德雷克所传达的那种狂妄和兴奋感产生了共鸣。嗯，这就是让他闻名全欧洲的原因，不是吗？他完成了一次惊人的政变。我的意思是，别忘了，他是弱者，英国人在这一切中是弱者。是的，他是罗宾汉。我的意思是，他绝对就是这里的罗宾汉。
And I think that's why Drake becomes so kind of loved and at, mired, is that people, even the Spanish to a degree, kind of respond to the sense of swagger and excitement that Drake conveys. Well, that's what makes him so famous across Europe, isn't it? The fact that he has pulled off a tremendous coup. I mean, don't forget, he's the underdog, the English of the underdogs and all this. Yeah, he's Robin Hood. I mean, he absolutely is the Robin Hood here.
是的。我告诉你，有一个人真的坐起来并注意到了，这就是我们在节目中提到过很多次的弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆，伊丽莎白的首席秘书。间谍大师。是的。所以他，我的意思是，他对被夺走的钱很感兴趣，但他同样感兴趣的是得知德雷克正在梦想另一次更大胆的远征。
Yeah. And I'll tell you, one person who really sits up and pays attention is someone we've mentioned a lot on this show, and this is Francis Walsingham, Elizabeth. first secretary. Spymaster. Yeah. And so he, I mean, he's intrigued by the money that's been taken, but he's intrigued as well to learn that Drake is dreaming of another even bolder expedition.
这就是德雷克在站在那个树屋里凝视太平洋时最初设想的远征。这是一次将引领他走向世界尽头的远征。世界的尽头。好吧，休息后回来，我们将航行到世界的另一端。在宜家，
And this is an expedition that Drake had first envisaged while he was standing in that treehouse gazing out towards the Pacific. And this is an expedition that will lead him to the very ends of the earth. The ends of the earth. Well, come back after the break when we'll be sailing to the far side of the world. At IKEA,
我们制造专为大学生活设计的东西，比如灰色的罗森曼德尔遮光窗帘。他们说睡眠是无价的，但我们给它定了个价，仅需49.99美元。你为什么在我的房间里？嘘，回去睡觉。你明天有场大考。在宜家选购返校用品。
we make things just for college life, like the Rosenmandel blackout curtains in gray. They say you can't put a price on sleep, but we did for the low, low price of $49.99. Why are you in my room? Shh, go back to sleep. You have a big exam tomorrow. shop back to school at IKEA.
欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1577年11月15日下午5点，我们在德文郡，具体是在普利茅斯湾，一支由五艘小船组成的船队正悄悄驶出港口，当然，他们由弗朗西斯·德雷克率领，乘坐他的旗舰，这艘船是一年前按照他的个人要求建造的。这是英国历史上最著名的船只之一。它就是“鹈鹕号”。但如果你把它与英国历史上的其他伟大船只（如胜利号）相比，
Welcome back to the rest is history. It's 5 o'clock in the afternoon of the 15th of November 1577, and we are in Devon, specifically at Plymouth Sound, where a flotilla of five small ships is slipping out into the harbor, and they are led, of course, by Francis Drake, aboard his flagship, which had been built to his personal, requirements a year before. And this is one of the most famous ships in English history. It is the Pelican. But if you compare it to other great ships in English history like HMS Victory,
我的意思是，“鹈鹕号”太小了，不是吗？它只有80英尺长。它只有18门炮，150吨。有一个鹈鹕号，我想，是在南威克吗？那里有一个鹈鹕号的复制品？是的，有一个复制品。所以你可以看到它是什么样子。顺便说一句，这艘船正如你所说，是英国历史上最著名的船只之一，但它并不以“鹈鹕号”的名字闻名，因为鹈鹕号的名字将在航行过程中更改。是的，我们不想泄露秘密，对吧？不。所以德雷克正带着他的五艘小船组成的舰队驶向比斯开湾，
I mean, the Pelican is tiny, isn't it? It's only 80 feet long. It's so got only 18 guns, 150 tons. There is a pelican, I think, is it Southwick where there's a replica of the pelican? Yeah, there's a replica of it. So you can see what it's like. And just to say, this ship is as you say one of the most famous ships in English history but it's not known as the Pelican so the Pelican's name will be changed in the course of the voyage. Yeah, we don't want to give the game away though, do we? No. So Drake is heading out in the Pelican with his fleet of five small ships into the Bay of Biscay
他的船上环绕着他所爱的人。所以他有他的兄弟托马斯，他有他15岁的表弟约翰，还有迭戈，他从西班牙主岛和他一起来的，现在正和他一起踏上这次新的冒险。他的船舱里有书，所以他当然有《圣经》。他有《福克斯殉道者名录》，那本伟大的新教殉道者汇编。他有一本诗篇歌集，所以人们可以坐在甲板上唱诗篇，非常虔诚。但他也有关于航海的书。
and he is surrounded on his ship with people he loves. So he's got his brother Thomas, he's got his 15-year-old cousin John, and he has Diego, who had come with him from the Spanish main and his is going off with him on this new adventure. He has books in his cabin, so he's got the Bible, of course. He's got Fox's Book of Martyrs, that great compendium of Protestant martyrs. He's got a songbook of the Psalms, so people can sit on the deck and sing the Psalms, all very godly. But he also has books on navigation.
其中之一是关于大约60年前由一位名叫费尔南·麦哲伦的葡萄牙探险家领导的西班牙远征队的记录。这是一次真正打破纪录的远征。它于1519年从西班牙出发。它一直沿着南美洲的大西洋海岸南下。在南美洲的尽头，它发现了一些危险但可航行的海峡。这些海峡后来以麦哲伦的名字命名，即麦哲伦海峡。麦哲伦带领他的远征队穿过了这些海峡，然后横渡太平洋并继续向西航行。在此过程中，他们发现了后来被称为菲律宾的地方，它们在
And one of these is an account of a Spanish expedition that had been led by a Portuguese explorer called Ferdinand Magellan, almost 60 years before. And this had been a really record-breaking expedition. So it had set off in 1519 from Spain. And it had gone all the way down the Atlantic coast of South America. And at the foot of South America, it had discovered some dangerous but navigable straits. These straits come to be called after Magellan, the Magellan Straits. And Magellan had led his expedition through these Straits, and had then crossed the Pacific and continued westwards. In the course of this, they had discovered what in due course come to be called the Philippines, and they're named the Philippines in
1542年以菲利普的名字命名，菲利普最终将成为西班牙国王，也就是伊丽莎白一世的死敌。麦哲伦在菲律宾被杀，最终，麦哲伦的远征队中只有一艘船“维多利亚号”幸存下来，于1522年抵达西班牙。但这显然是一个打破纪录的、具有地震般意义的成就，因为“维多利亚号”是第一艘环绕全球的船只。这次航行的历史对德雷克来说似乎是一个奇怪的携带物，因为官方上他的远征队正前往地中海的亚历山大港和君士坦丁堡进行贸易远征。这就是他船上那160多名男人和男孩被告知的内容，
1542 after the Philip, who is going to end up the king of Spain, the man who becomes Elizabeth the first great enemy. McGillen is killed in the Philippines, and ultimately, of McGillan's expedition, only a single ship, the Victoria survives to reach Spain in 1522. But it is, obviously a record-breaking and seismic achievement because the Victoria is the first ship ever to have circumnavigated the entire globe. And a history of this voyage might seem an odd thing for Drake to have brought with him on his expedition, because officially his expedition is heading to Alexandria and Constantinople in the Mediterranean on a trading expedition. And this is what the 160 odd kind of men and boys on board his expedition have all been told,
这也是西班牙间谍向菲利普二世报告的内容。你知道，他们计划去地中海。是的。但我认为如果菲利普的间谍稍微细心一点，他们可能会得出不同的结论。所以如果他们查看了这些船只的货舱，他们会发现里面装满了军火。比如长矛、弩、火枪和各种燃烧弹。此外，德雷克在这次远征中还带了一名律师。同样，这不是你通常会带去地中海贸易旅行的东西。
And it's also what Spanish spies have reported back to Philip the second. You know, they are planning to go to the Mediterranean. Yeah. But I think had Philip spies been a bit more attentive, they might have come to a different conclusion. So if they had looked into the holds of the holds of these ships, they would have found that they were full of armaments. So pikes and crossbows and muskets and kind of various kinds of incendiaries. Also, Drake has a lawyer with him on board this expedition. Again, not something that you would generally take with you on a trading trip to the Mediterranean.
这是一个名叫托马斯·道蒂的人，他是德雷克两年前在爱尔兰结识的朋友。道蒂是一个非常有学问、迷人、受过高等教育的人。所以他与德雷克属于完全不同的阶层。他是一位绅士。德雷克绝对不是绅士。而道蒂是伊丽莎白宫廷中一位关键人物的秘书。这是一个名叫克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士的人。
And this is a guy called Thomas Doughty, who is a friend that Drake had made two years before while in Ireland. And Doughty is a very learned, charming, highly educated man. So a very different class of person to Drake. He's a gentleman. Drake is absolutely not a gentleman. And Doughty is secretary. to a key figure in Elizabeth's court. And this is a guy called Sir Christopher Hatton.
女王本人非常崇拜哈顿。哈顿是女王最宠爱的朝臣之一。他非常英俊。他风趣幽默。他是个出色的舞者。所以正是伊丽莎白倾向于喜欢的那种人。她任命哈顿为枢密院绅士，皇家卫队队长。
And the queen herself adores Hatton. Hatton is one of the queen's favorite courtiers. He's very handsome. He's witty. He's a good dancer. So exactly the kind of guy that Elizabeth tends to go for. And she has made Hatton a gentleman of the privy chamber, captain of the yeoman of the guard.
这两项职责意味着哈顿总是亲自侍奉女王。所以非常多地围着她转。是的，是的。她赐予他各种恩宠的标志，各种礼物。这包括伦敦边缘的伊利主教的庄园。这就是被称为哈顿花园的地区名字的由来。哈顿花园是珠宝商所在地。
And both of those responsibilities means that Hatton is always in attendance, personally on the queen. So very much kind of hanging around her. Yeah, yeah. And she bestows all kinds of marks of favour, all kinds of gifts on him. And this includes the estate of the Bishop of Ely on the margins of London. And this is where the region called Hatton Gardens gets its name from. Hatton Gardens is where the jewelers are.
它总是出现在盖·里奇的电影中，比如炸开保险箱之类的。这是以克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士的名字命名的。伊丽莎白不仅钦佩哈顿的舞技，还钦佩他的忠诚和政治精明。因此，在德雷克离开普利茅斯的三天前，伊丽莎白任命哈顿为枢密院成员。我认为这并非巧合，因为现在有了一个非常明确的指挥链。你有女王，你有哈顿和枢密院，而哈顿的秘书道蒂正与德雷克一起
It always kind of features in Guy Ritchie films where it blowing up the safe, all that kind of thing. And this is named after Sir Christopher Hatton. And Elizabeth not only admires Hatton's ability as a dancer, but also his loyalty and his political shrewdness. And so three days before Drake leaves Plymouth, Elizabeth makes Hatton a member of the Privy Council. I think this isn't coincidental because there is now a very clear chain of command. You have the Queen, you have Hatton and the Privy Council, and Hatton's secretary, Doughty, is with Drake
参加这次远征。所以那里与女王本人有非常明确的联系。那么，你之前提到的弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆，那位伟大的间谍大师呢？他也有关联，不是吗？嗯，他是这次远征的直接投资者，就像哈顿和道蒂一样。他一直在代表德雷克牵线搭桥。所以，在德雷克离开普利茅斯湾的前几个月，沃尔辛厄姆安排他与伊丽莎白进行了一次私人会谈。根据德雷克后来对女王所说内容的描述，基本上她正在提升他的
on this expedition. So there are very clear links there to the Queen herself. And what about some, you mentioned Francis Wilsingham before the Great, the great spymaster. There are associations with him as well, aren't there? Well, he's a direct investor in the expedition, Lighthatton and Light Doughty. And he's also been pulling strings on Drake's behalf. So a few months before Drake leaves Plymouth Sound, Walsingham had arranged for him to have a private interview with Elizabeth. And according to Drake's later account of what the Queen said, basically she is upgrading him
级别，从海盗提升为私掠船长。所以女王据称对德雷克说，我很高兴能为我所受到的各种伤害向西班牙国王复仇。德雷克向女王提出了一个他酝酿已久的计划。那就是穿过麦哲伦海峡，攻击美国太平洋沿岸的西班牙船只，并掠夺它们的所有价值。这个计划的天才之处在于，西班牙人根本不会预料到这一点，因为实际上，包括麦哲伦在内，到目前为止，只有三次远征穿过了麦哲伦海峡。它们就是那么危险。
from the rank of pirate to privateer. So the Queen supposedly said to Drake, I would gladly be revenged on the King of Spain for diverse injuries that I have received. And Drake had suggested to the Queen a plan that he had been mulling over a long time. And this is namely to sail through the Magellan Straits, attack the Spanish ships off the Pacific coast of America and to plunder them for all their worth. And the genius of this is that there is no way the Spanish will be expecting it because they've actually, including Magellons, up until this point, they've only been three expeditions through the Magellan Straits. They are that dangerous.
所以西班牙人，正如我们所听到的，倾向于通过诺姆德迪奥斯和那条通往巴拿马的骡道进入太平洋。因此，他们认为他们对太平洋沿岸的控制是绝对的。你知道，其他欧洲船只根本无法到达那里。所以他们称太平洋本身为“封闭海”。是的。为了让人们对地图有个概念，如果你不通过巴拿马陆路，进入太平洋的唯一可能方式就是沿着基本上
And so the Spanish, as we've been hearing, tend to access the Pacific via Nomrididos and that mule train over to Panama. And so therefore they assume that their control over, the Pacific coast is absolute. You know, there are, there's no way that other European ships can get there. And so they call the Pacific itself, the Marley-Clausum, the closed sea. Yeah. Just to give people a sense about the map, the only way you can possibly get to the Pacific, if you don't go overland through Panama, is to go all the way down the coast of basically
巴西、乌拉圭、阿根廷的海岸一直南下，绕过阿根廷的底部，然后再沿另一侧北上。这太困难了，以至于你会疯了才会去尝试。是的，更准确地说，他们在这个阶段还不知道后来成为阿根廷的地方有一个底部。他们还不知道阿根廷以南除了开阔的海洋外什么都没有。所以这就是海峡如此重要的原因。女王听了这一切，认为这绝对太棒了。她基本上说，是的，我喜欢这个。但伊丽莎白毕竟是伊丽莎白，她非常非常精明，非常谨慎。她不想把任何东西写下来。你知道，她想让德雷克在某个时候去
Brazil, Uruguay, Argentina, around the bottom of Argentina, and then up the other side. And that is so difficult that you will. would be mad to attempt it. Yeah, and just to be even more precise, they don't at this stage know that what will become Argentina has a kind of bottom, as it were. They're not yet aware that there is just nothing but open ocean south of Argentina. So that's why the straits are so important. And the queen hears all this and she thinks it's absolutely brilliant. And she essentially says, yeah, I love this. But Elizabeth being Elizabeth, she's very, very cany, she's very cautious. She doesn't want to put anything in writing. You know, she wants Drake to go in a time.
对付西班牙人，但她也想要否认权。德雷克本人对这种安排非常满意，因为他真正想要的是，无论他做什么，女王私下里都会支持他。伊丽莎白在德雷克离开前说，如果需要，这位绅士不在乎，我会否认他。他们基本上互相理解。对。顺便说一句，伊丽莎白显然非常崇拜德雷克。她认为他很了不起，正如我们稍后会看到的。所以，虽然从未写下来，但这确实是计划。德雷克将如你所说，沿着南美洲的大西洋海岸南下。
the Spanish, but she also wants deniability. And Drake himself is perfectly happy with this arrangement, because the one thing that he really wants is that whatever he does, the queen privately will have his back. And Elizabeth says about Drake before he leaves, if need be, the gentleman careth not, I should disavow him. They basically understand each other. Right. And just to say, Elizabeth, she clearly adores Drake. She thinks she's tremendous, as we will see in due course. So, although it is never written down, this is the plan. Drake is going to sail, as you said, down the Atlantic coast of South America.
他将到达麦哲伦海峡，穿过这些海峡，进入太平洋。然后他将沿着美洲西海岸北上。基本上，他会像一只闯入鸡舍的狐狸。他会尽可能多地夺取战利品。他会绘制海岸线，以供未来英国冒险参考。然后他将原路返回。换句话说，通过麦哲伦海峡。目前没有计划遵循麦哲伦的路线环游世界。因为这在每个人看来基本上都是疯狂的路线。它太危险了。
He's going to reach the Magellan Straits, go through these straits, into the Pacific. He's then going to head up the west coast of the Americas. And essentially, he will be like a fox who has broken into a chicken coop. He's going to take as many prizes as he can. He's going to map the coastline for future reference for later English adventure. And then he's going to return the way he came. So in other words, via the Straits of Magellan. There is no plan at this point to follow McGillen's route all the way around the world. Because that essentially is seen by everyone as a mad course. It's way, way too dangerous.
嗯，麦哲伦本人死了。是的，正是如此。正是如此。自那次尝试以来，没有其他人尝试过。没有其他人尝试过环游世界。你知道，这根本不是人们认为应该或能够尝试的事情。所以这就是德雷克的计划。进入太平洋，掠夺它，绘制地图，然后通过麦哲伦海峡和北大西洋回到英国。于是他们出发了，起初一切似乎都很顺利。他们在11月穿过了北大西洋的暴风雨天气。
Well, McGowan himself died. Yes, exactly. Exactly. And since that first attempt, no one else has tried to do it. No one else has tried to sail around the world. you know, it's just not something that people think should, should or could be, be tried. So that's, that's Drake's plan. Get into the Pacific, loot it, map it, and then come back to England by the, by the, by the McGowan Straits and up the Atlantic. And so they set off and at first everything seems to be going well. They make it through the stormy weather of the North Atlantic in November.
很快人们就发现他们不是去地中海，但德雷克的手下并没有因此感到特别困惑。我对此感到震惊。他们中肯定有些人一定知道。我的意思是，货舱里有炸药的事实。是的，得了吧。我想是的。而且，德雷克，到这个时候，是英国最有魅力的船长。
It soon becomes apparent that they're not going to the Mediterranean, but Drake's men aren't particularly discombobulated by this. I'm struck by this. Surely some of them must have known. I mean, the fact that, you know, there are explosives in the whole. Yeah, come on. I think so. And also, Drake is, you know, by this point, is the most charismatic sea captain in England.
你知道，他非常受欢迎。他非常受人钦佩。当他说，我们要去弄到一大堆战利品时，人们相信他。果然，他们很快就都，你知道，他们玩得很开心，攻击葡萄牙船只，把它们作为战利品，绑架葡萄牙领航员。你知道，他们可以利用他们所有的地图和他们的航海知识，所有这些。但当他们向南航行前往麦哲伦海峡时，英国历史上一直存在并至今仍然存在的一个主题开始抬头。
You know, he's very popular. He's very admired. And when he says, we're going to get loads of loot, people believe him. And sure enough, they're soon all, you know, they're having a lovely time, attacking Portuguese ships, taking them as prizes, kidnapping Portuguese pilots. You know, they can then use all their maps and their kind of nautical know-how, all of this. But as they sail southwards down towards the Magellan Straits, what has always been a theme in English history and remains so to this day, starts to raise its head.
这就是阶级问题。我喜欢这个细节。所以德雷克船上处于危险之中的是道蒂（律师）和德雷克之间的职位争夺。道蒂是那位在宫廷中有亲密联系的绅士，是克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士的门生，而哈顿是伊丽莎白本人极其亲近的朝臣；而德雷克，是一个雄心勃勃的德文郡人，肩上背负着巨大的自卑感。
And this is the issue of class. I love this detail. So at stake on Drake's ship is a jockeying for position between Doughty, the lawyer. the gentleman with intimate connections at court, the protege of Sir Christopher Hatton, who is the incredibly close courtier to Elizabeth herself, and Drake, who is an upwardly mobile son of Devon with a massive chip on his shoulder.
道蒂，作为绅士应有的权利，坚持要求根据他的等级应得的权利。而德雷克则要求即使是像道蒂这样的绅士也必须全力以赴。所以这两个最初是朋友的人之间产生了日益增长的紧张关系。德雷克确实尝试过各种方法来安抚道蒂。所以首先他给了他一艘被俘获的葡萄牙船的指挥权。
And Doughty, as is due as a gentleman, insists on the rights that are due to him by virtue of his rank. While Drake is demanding that even a gentleman like Doughty has to put his shoulder to the wheel, And so there's a growing tension between these two men who initially had been friends. And Drake does make various attempts to mollify Doughty. So first he gives him the command of a captured Portuguese ship.
然后他令人惊讶地给了他“鹈鹕号”本身的指挥权。也就是德雷克自己的旗舰。但尽管有这些，你知道，建立桥梁的尝试，关系仍然恶化。道蒂指控德雷克的兄弟从一堆被俘获的葡萄酒中偷窃。他开始对德雷克本人发表评论。这显然已经接近叛变了。德雷克开始认为道蒂正在对他施展巫术。他真的这么认为吗，还是这只是一个武器？
And then he gives him command amazingly of the Pelican itself. So Drake's own flagship. But despite these, you know, attempts to build bridges, relations still worsen. And Doughty accuses Drake's brother of stealing from a captured hall of wine. And he starts to make comments about Drake himself. that are clearly verging on the mutinous. And Drake starts to think that Doughty is practicing witchcraft against him. Does he really think this or is this just a weapon?
我想他是真的相信。你知道，你在海上。德雷克是一个非常虔诚的人。我想他认为道蒂之所以会这样表现，唯一的原因就是他与魔鬼勾结。我一点也不觉得这个论点有什么漏洞。对。好吧。
I think he really believes it. You know, you're at sea. Drake is a very pious man. I think he thinks the only reason that Doughty could be behaving like this is because he's in Hock with the devil. I don't see the floor in that argument at all. Right. Okay.
这完全是自然而然的。最后，发生了一系列非常公开的争吵，这些争吵是在所有船员的直接注视下发生的。所以首先，德雷克非常公开地将道蒂从“鹈鹕号”的指挥官降职为一艘名为“天鹅号”的小型补给船的指挥官。然后他将他直接置于他的副指挥官的监护之下。他警告副指挥官和“鹈鹕号”上的每个人，道蒂是一个煽动者，一个非常糟糕和淫荡的家伙。
It comes completely naturally. And finally, there is a series of very open bust-ups, which are happening in direct view of all the crew. So firstly, Drake very publicly demotes Doughty from his command of the Pelican to command of a tiny supply vessel called the Swan. And then he places him directly in the custody of his vice admiral. And he warns the vice admiral and everybody on board the pelican that Doughty is a cundra, a seditious fellow and a very bad and lewd fellow.
所以基本上，道蒂，到这个时候，你知道，他已经被戴上了镣铐。是的。在这个阶段，他们比历史上任何英国船只都走得更远。他们驶入了一个名为圣朱利安的海湾，位于现在的阿根廷海岸。他们在6月20日那里抛锚。在圣朱利安湾，非常有那种《金银岛》的感觉，非常《加勒比海盗》。在海湾的海岸线上，他们发现了一个绞刑架，麦哲伦曾带着他的船队到达那里，你知道，
So essentially, Doughty, by this point, you know, he's been clapped in irons. Yeah. And by this stage, their further. than any English ship before them ever in history. And they sail into a bay called San Julien on the coast of what is now Argentina. And they make anchor there on the 20th of June. And in the bay of San Julien, it's very kind of treasure island, very pirates of the Caribbean. On the kind of the shoreline of the bay, they find a gallows from which Magellan, who'd arrived there, you know, with his flotilla.
绞死了一个叛变者，那个叛变者的漂白骨架仍然在绞刑架上。天哪。太精彩了。所以德雷克的船员看到了这个叛变者的骨头。他们对德雷克说，好吧，这就是你处理叛变者的方法。你应该对道蒂这样做。
had hanged a mutineer, and the bleached skeleton of the mutineer is still there in the jibbit. Oh my God. That's brilliant. So Drake's crew see the bones of this mutineer. They say to Drake, well, this is how you deal with mutineers. You should do this to Doughty.
天哪，这太《加勒比海盗》或《金银岛》之类的了，不是吗？确实如此。所以德雷克想，是的，为什么不呢？好吧。所以在6月30日，他召集他的手下到海湾中的一个小岛上。道蒂被带出来，你知道，戴着镣铐。德雷克对他进行了审判。
God, this is so Pirates to Caribbean, a Treasure Island or something, isn't it? It really is. And so Drake thinks, yeah, why not? Okay. So on the 30th of June, he summons his men to an island out in the bay. And Doughty is brought out, you know, clapped in irons. And Drake puts him on trial.
而道蒂，当然，是一名律师。所以道蒂说，好吧，你凭什么权利这样做？你知道，给我看你的女王委任状。而德雷克没有女王的委任状，因为他，你知道，是在雷达下行动。所以德雷克，当然，不是律师，但他是一个行动派。是的。我不关心那个。谁在乎法律条文呢？
And Doughty, of course, is a lawyer. So Doughty says, well, by what right are you doing this? You know, show me your commission from the queen. And Drake doesn't have a commission from the queen because he's, you know, operating under the radar. So Drake, who, of course, is not a lawyer, but he's very much a man of action. Yeah. I don't care about that. Who cares about the letter of the law?
他转向他的手下说，这家伙满嘴废话。绑住他的手臂，因为我要保住我的性命。他召集了一个陪审团，对道蒂进行了审判，并说出了指控：叛国罪和煽动叛乱。这当然是对德雷克权威的一次巨大、巨大的考验。这是一个德雷克通过了的考验。而一旦那个考验通过，真的只能有一个判决。因为德雷克在召集陪审团时对他的手下说，想想我们要进行的这次伟大的航行，英国从未有过这样的航行。我们不能容忍船上有异议。你知道，我们甚至不能容忍叛变的威胁。所以，
And he turns to his men and he says, this fellow is full of prate. bind me his arms, for I will be safe of my life. And he convenes a jury and he puts doughty on trial and says the charges, treason and incitement to mutiny. And this, of course, is a massive, massive test of Drake's authority. And it's a test which Drake passes. And the moment that that test has been passed, there can really be only the one verdict. Because Drake says to his men when he's kind of, you know, commissioning the jury, consider what a great voyage we are like to make, the like was never made out of England. We cannot afford to have dissension on board our ships. You know, we cannot tolerate even the threat of mutiny. And so,
不出所料，陪审团裁定道蒂有罪，并建议判处死刑。德雷克确实推诿了。你知道，他和道蒂曾经是朋友。而且，道蒂是克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士的秘书，而哈顿是伊丽莎白最宠爱的人。我的意思是，这是一个大赌注。这是高风险，是的。非常高风险。但是，你知道，他说，好吧，我判处道蒂死刑。而道蒂，不得不说他非常非常勇敢地面对了他的命运。德雷克和道蒂令人惊讶地分享了道蒂的最后一餐。
unsurprisingly, the jury finds Doughty guilty and they recommend death. Drake does prevaricate. You know, he and Doughty had been friends. And also, Doughty is the secretary of Sir Christopher Hatton, who is this great favourite of Elizabeth. I mean, it's a big art. This is high risk, yeah. Very high risk. But, you know, he says, okay, I'm sentencing Doughty to death. And Doughty to give him great credit meets his fate very, very bravely. And Drake and Doughty amazingly, they share Doughty's last meal.
这太离奇了。引用航行记录的话说，他们像以往任何时候一样，清醒而愉快地分享了它，互相鼓励，并像只是要进行某种旅程一样互相告别。我的意思是，那顿饭一定很特别。我的意思是，互相鼓励让我觉得这是一个荒谬的说法。我的意思是，我能看出道蒂需要鼓励。但德雷克也需要鼓励，真的，我的意思是，嗯，德雷克有点沮丧，因为他不得不这样做。我想他可能担心克里斯托弗·哈顿会说什么。我不觉得这是道蒂的工作，真的，在最后时刻去鼓励弗朗西斯·德雷克。嗯，我想你可以说这是完全编造的，或者你可以说，
That's bizarre. And to quote the record of the voyage, they shared it as cheerfully in sobriety as ever in their lives they had done a foretime, each cheering up the other and taking their leave by drinking each to other as if some journey only. had been in hand. I mean, what a meal that must have been. I mean, each cheering up the other just strikes me as a ludicrous claim. I mean, I can see that doubt he needs cheering up. But for Drake to need cheering up, really, I mean, well, Drake's a bit depressed that he's had to do this. I think he's probably worried about what Christopher Hatton's going to say. I don't feel like this is doubt his job, really, to cheer the Francis Drake up in his final moments. Well, I think you could either say this was completely made up, or you could say,
嗯，这反映了这两个人非常了不起。是的。并延伸到英国。所以这很好。绝对。所以这更有理由相信它。所以他们吃完了饭，然后道蒂被带上前，他的头被砍了下来，德雷克举起那颗被砍下的头颅大喊，看，这就是叛徒的下场。这就是道蒂的结局。这是一个非常残酷的插曲。它很有争议。但我认为这是一种权宜之计。德雷克这样做了，他是对的，因为这非常清晰且果断地确立了指挥链。德雷克负责这次远征，没有别人。而且，我认为，由于德雷克的名声，它有助于建立一个非常重要的先例，即船长在自己船上的权威高于其他人，甚至是绅士。你可能会说，正是因为德雷克以这种方式在道蒂面前坚持自己，所以1912年泰坦尼克号撞上冰山时，查尔斯·莱托拉，那个负责在沉没的泰坦尼克号上分配救生艇的人，能够告诉船上最富有的人阿斯特，不，你不能上船，而阿斯特接受了那个指示。我的意思是，我认为那里有一条非常迷人的传承线。是的。但显然，我认为德雷克，他冒了险，因为也许他的船员不会支持他。
well, this reflects tremendously well on both men. Yeah. And by extension, on England. So that's nice. Absolutely. So that's all the more reason for believing it. So they finished their meal and then Doughty is brought forward and his head is chopped off and Drake lifts the severed head and cries out, low, this is the end of traitors. And that is the end of Doughty. And it's a very brutal episode. It's controversial. But I think it is an act of expediency. Drake did it and he was right to do it because it very clearly and disliked. decisively established the chain of command. Drake is in charge of the expedition, no one else. And it also, I think, because of Drake's fame, it serves to establish a very important precedent, namely that the
事实证明他们支持了。但他也在冒险，因为他不知道这回到家后会怎么样。克里斯托弗·哈顿会说什么？伊丽莎白会说什么？所以他们在8月20日到达麦哲伦海峡，并在那里停顿。这是一个非常令人望而生畏的景象，就像《奥德赛》里的东西。悬崖显得阴沉、灰暗且令人望而生畏。德雷克在进入海峡之前，向女王致敬。
authority of a captain on board his own ship outranks that of everyone else, even a gentleman. And you might say that it is because Drake asserted himself over Doughty in this manner, that in 1912 when the Titanic hit the iceberg, Charles Lytola, the guy in charge of allocating people to the lifeboats on the sinking Titanic, was able to tell Astor the richest man on board the ship, no, you can't get in board, and Astor accepted that instruction. I mean, there's a kind of really fascinating line of descent there, I think. Yeah. But clearly, I think Drake, he'd taken a risk because perhaps his crew wouldn't back him in.
显然，这是有记录的。他展示了他对伊丽莎白的尊重。他举行了教堂仪式。我相信他们正在唱诗篇歌集里的诗篇。然后他为他的船重新命名。曾经的“鹈鹕号”变成了“金鹿号”。而“金鹿号”是克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士的纹章。真是个聪明的把戏。
They've turned out that they have. But he is also taking a risk because he doesn't know how this is going to go back home. What's the Christopher Hatton going to say? What's Elizabeth going to say? And so they arrive at the Magellan Straits on the 20th of August, and they pause there. And it's a very forbidding sight, like something out of the Odyssey. The cliffs are kind of grim and gray and forbidding. And Drake, before they enter the straits, he offers a salute to the queen.
真是个好细节。是的。当你看到关于弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士的儿童读物时，或者至少是我读过的那些，故事的这一方面从未被提及。稍微掩盖了一下。是的。因为这有点复杂，而且我认为这反映了弗朗西斯·德雷克相当糟糕的一面，而在现实中。
And obviously, this is recorded. He's showing his respect for Elizabeth. He holds a church service. I'm sure they're singing from the hymn book of the Psalmity or the Psalms. And then he rechristens his ship. And what had been the pelican becomes the golden hind. And the golden hind is the crest of Sir Christopher Hatton. Such a clever trick.
我不认为这反映得很糟糕。我认为他，你知道，他坚持了自己。嗯，我想如果你八岁，你会对这个故事感到有点困惑。是的，从未解释为什么“鹈鹕号”变成了“金鹿号”，但这就是原因。所以无论如何，我们现在来到穿过麦哲伦海峡的通道。这有点像，你知道，阿尔戈英雄穿过碰撞岩。这是一次非常紧张的经历。
Such a good detail that. Yeah. When you see the kids' books about Sir Francis Strait or at least the ones I read, this aspect of the story was never mentioned. slightly covered over. Yeah. Because it's a little bit complicated and it reflects quite badly on Francis Drake, I think, whereas in reality.
海峡长约300英里，非常险恶。有暗礁、危险的风和不规则的潮汐。所以这是一个巨大的挑战，挑战大到德雷克实际上放弃了他的五艘船中的两艘，因为他觉得它们不适航，无法进行尝试。然而，我很自豪地说，德雷克完全成功了。所以他只用了15天就通过了海峡，而麦哲伦用了37天，德雷克创下了整个16世纪的纪录。所以这对德雷克来说反映良好。这对英国来说反映良好。
I don't think it reflects badly. I think he's, you know, he's asserted himself. Well, I think if you're eight, you would be a little bit confused by this story. Yeah, it's never explained why the Pelican becomes the golden hind, but that's the reason. So anyway, we now come to the passage through the McGillen Straits. And this is a bit like, you know, the Argonauts going through the clashing rocks. It's a very tense experience.
万岁。哇。他们从另一边出来。他们现在在太平洋了。有一场巨大的风暴。它断断续续地肆虐了近两个月。德雷克的一艘船沉没了，另一艘与“金鹿号”失散，被吹回了麦哲伦海峡，并最终想，
The Straits are kind of, 300 miles long and they're very treacherous. There are reefs and dangerous winds and erratic tides. So it's it's a big ask and it's such a big ask that in fact Drake abandons two of his five ships because he feels that they're unseaworthy to make the attempt. However, I'm proud to say Drake completely aces it. So he negotiates the straits in only 15 days and Magellan had taken 37 days and Drake sets the record for the whole of the 16th century. So this reflects well on Drake. It reflects well on England.
哦，去他的。我们要回家了。于是它回去了。所以现在在太平洋的浩瀚中，“金鹿号”是唯一剩下的英国船只。所以这非常科幻。就像《航海家号》或《星际穿越》之类的东西。一种船只迷失在太平洋浩瀚或太空浩瀚中的感觉。
Hooray. Wow. They come out the other side. They're now in the Pacific. And there's a massive storm. And it rages on and off for almost two months. And one of Drake's ships is sunk and the other is separated from the golden hind and is blown back towards the Magellan Straits and kind of ends up thinking,
太好了。哇。他们从另一边出来了。他们现在进入了太平洋。那里有一场巨大的风暴。它断断续续地肆虐了近两个月。德雷克的一艘船沉没了，另一艘与“金鹿号”失散，被吹回了麦哲伦海峡，最后他们心想，
oh, screw this. We're going to go back home. And so it goes back. And so now in all the great vastness of the Pacific, The Golden Hind is the only English ship left. So it's very science fiction. It's like kind of Voyager or interstellar or something like that. The sense of a ship lost in the vastness of Pacific or the vastness of space.
噢，去他的。我们要回家了。于是它就回去了。现在在广袤无垠的太平洋上，“金鹿号”成了唯一剩下的英国船只。这非常有科幻感。就像《航海家号》或《星际穿越》之类的作品。那种船只迷失在浩瀚太平洋或浩瀚太空中的感觉。
I mean, it's an amazing, an amazing drama. And incredible tribute to Drake that he doesn't at this point think, well, I'd better go back to. He's still thinking, I've got here, I'm going to take my chances. But to do what? Because there's just one of him. Yeah. Well, that's the problem. So he can't now launch a direct attack, say, on Panama.
我的意思是，这是一部了不起的戏剧。德雷克令人难以置信的敬业精神在于，他此时并没有想“我最好还是回去吧”。他仍在想，“我已经到了这里，我要抓住机会”。但要做什么呢？因为他只有一个人。是的，这就是问题所在。所以他现在无法对巴拿马发动直接攻击。
And also, he has a very finite number of men. So every casualty matters. So in November, for instance, he suffers the loss of two sailors when the native peoples on an island off Chile mistake the English for Spanish, who, you know, they know that the Spanish are bad news. The English are trying to make friends with them, but no, they're not having that. And Drake himself actually gets hit in the face under his right eye by an arrow. and Diego too suffers an arrow wound and very sadly he will die of this wound a few months later so he doesn't make it all the way around the world
而且，他的人数非常有限。所以每一次伤亡都很重要。例如，在十一月，当智利附近岛屿上的原住民误将英国人当作西班牙人时，他损失了两名水手，因为他们知道西班牙人不是好东西。英国人试图与他们交朋友，但对方并不领情。德雷克本人右眼下方实际上被箭射中，迭戈也受了箭伤，非常遗憾的是，几个月后他因伤去世，所以他没能完成环球航行。
but you know why is Drake deciding well we're going to carry on because the Spanish aren't expecting him and so that means they are incredibly vulnerable and so he you know I said he's like a kind of fox in a chicken coop there are a lot of chickens and the most spectacular coup is the capture of An enormous Spanish treasure ship, Our Signora de la Concepcion.
但你知道德雷克为什么决定“我们要继续前进”吗？因为西班牙人没有预料到他，这意味着他们极其脆弱。所以我说他就像鸡舍里的狐狸，那里有很多鸡，而最壮观的战利品是捕获了一艘巨大的西班牙宝船——“圣母受孕号”。
And this gives Drake 14 chests of silver reales. This is so Treasure Island. 80 pounds of gold, 26 tons of silver bars. And so this is even more of a hall than Drake's previous hall of Spanish treasure. Probably the greatest, the single greatest hall of treasure in,
这给了德雷克14箱银里亚尔。这简直就是《金银岛》的情节。80磅黄金，26吨银条。所以这比德雷克之前捕获的西班牙财宝还要多。这可能是历史上单次捕获财宝最多的一次，
maybe European history. I don't know. I mean, it is a vast amount of money. Drake, I'm proud to say, treats the captured Spanish captain with exemplary chivalry. And it has to be said that Spaniards who meet Drake are generally despite themselves very impressed by his courtesy and his sense of chivalry. So I think, you know, they fear and hate him. But there is a sense, you know, it's a bit like the kind of the highwayman, the gentleman highwayman, something like that. Yeah.
也许是欧洲历史上最多的。我不知道。我的意思是，这是一笔巨额财富。我很自豪地说，德雷克以模范的骑士精神对待被俘的西班牙船长。必须说，见到德雷克的西班牙人尽管内心抵触，但通常对他的礼貌和骑士精神印象深刻。所以我认为，你知道，他们既恐惧又憎恨他。但有一种感觉，你知道，这有点像那种强盗，绅士强盗，类似那样。是的。
He also, any slaves that he finds on board the Spanish ships, he offers them their freedom and sailor. wages. And of course, most of the captured slaves take this offer up. And this is an obvious way for Drake to top up his crew. John, I'm getting massive sort of Tom Hiddleston, Roger Moore vibes from Sir Francis Drake. He's suave. Yeah, but remember, he's got, he's stocky and broad-shouldered, and he has a broad devoured accent, and he's not a gentleman. Yeah, I know. So if you're doing realistic casting, it's John Rhys Davis. It's the guy who paid Gimley. But I think you surely want more of a sort of a smooth, suave Englishman, sort of David Niven. I thank you for your offer of silver.
他还向他在西班牙船上发现的所有奴隶提供自由和水手工资。当然，大多数被俘的奴隶都接受了这个提议。这对德雷克来说是补充船员的明显方式。约翰，我在弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士身上感受到了强烈的汤姆·希德勒斯顿和罗杰·摩尔的气质。他很风度翩翩。是的，但记住，他身材结实，肩膀宽阔，有着浓重的德文郡口音，他不是绅士。是的，我知道。所以如果你要进行现实的选角，那是约翰·里斯-戴维斯。就是演吉姆利的那个人。但我认为你肯定想要一个更圆滑、更风度翩翩的英国人，比如大卫·尼文。我感谢你提供的白银。
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Maybe if you're doing comedy, Terry Thomas would play him. No, I don't think so. No, you've got to take him seriously. Really? You'd never do a Francis Drake comedy. You don't think that would work?
是的，完全正确。完全正确。也许如果你在拍喜剧，特里·托马斯会扮演他。不，我不这么认为。不，你必须认真对待他。真的吗？你永远不会拍弗朗西斯·德雷克的喜剧吗？你不认为那会奏效吗？
Carry on Drake. No. Carry on in the Caribbean. No, I think that would be offensive. I mean, the Spanish obviously don't find this a comedy. No, they don't. They're appalled. What are they planning to do?
《继续前进，德雷克》。不。《在加勒比海继续前进》。不，我认为那会令人反感。我的意思是，西班牙人显然不觉得这是喜剧。不，他们不觉得。他们感到震惊。他们打算做什么？
Well, they're thinking, how is Drake, you know, he's got all this silver and gold, but he's got to take it back home. How's you going to do it? So he might try and go overland from the Pacific coast across Panama to the Atlantic coast. And so they put garrisons in Panama on the alert in case he tries that. And then they think, well, he might, you know, try and go back through the Straits of Magellan. So we'll put patrols there. But Drake is aware that this is probably what they're thinking. And so instead of heading back south towards the Magellan Straits, he heads northward. in the hope of finding a northern passage. So around what, you know, would be Canada at this point. Drake doesn't know whether actually that that's impossible. And so he sails up the coast of South America, North America, and he reaches almost as far as what is now Canada by June 1579. And he starts to realize, you know, we're never going to find a way around this. It just goes on and on and on.
嗯，他们在想，德雷克，你知道，他有这么多金银，但他必须把它带回家。他打算怎么做？所以他可能会尝试从太平洋沿岸穿过巴拿马到达大西洋沿岸。因此，他们让巴拿马的驻军保持警惕，以防他尝试那样做。然后他们想，嗯，他可能，你知道，尝试穿过麦哲伦海峡回去。所以我们会在那里部署巡逻队。但德雷克意识到这很可能是他们的想法。因此，他没有向南朝麦哲伦海峡返回，而是向北航行，希望能找到一条北方通道。也就是现在的加拿大附近。德雷克不知道那实际上是否不可能。所以他沿着南美洲、北美洲的海岸航行，到1579年6月，他几乎到达了现在的加拿大。他开始意识到，你知道，我们永远找不到绕过这里的路。它只是没完没了。
So he heads back south. And by late June, early July, he's hanging out in the, the Bay Area. So hence, that's why you get Sir Francis Drake Boulevard and all of that. Right. And he makes contact with the native peoples in the region of what is going to become San Francisco. And these are people called the Miwok, who apparently were based in what's now Sonoma County. Wine country. Yeah, isn't that where we had a very expensive truffle crisp? I'm going to just absolutely destroy the reputation of the rest of history. It was you, me and Tabby, and we had an artisan Pringle topped with caviar. Tough on the road. isn't it tough on the road? Yeah.
所以他向南返回。到六月下旬、七月初，他待在湾区。所以，这就是为什么会有弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士大道之类的东西。对。他与后来成为旧金山的地区的当地原住民取得了联系。这些人被称为米沃克人，他们显然居住在现在的索诺马县。葡萄酒之乡。是的，那不是我们吃过非常昂贵的松露薯片的地方吗？我简直要彻底毁掉《历史的其余部分》的声誉了。那是你、我和塔比，我们吃了一种配鱼子酱的工匠品客薯片。在路上很艰难，不是吗？在路上很艰难？是的。
Well, Drake wasn't having any of that, but I think he is entertained by the, by the Milwaukee, and Drake reports of them that there are people of attractable, free and loving nature without guile or treachery. And the milok put a feathered crown
嗯，德雷克可没那闲工夫，但我认为他被米沃克人招待了，德雷克报告说他们是“天性温顺、自由且充满爱心，没有诡计或背叛的人”。米沃克人给德雷克戴上了一顶羽毛冠，
on Drake's head. And so obviously Drake says, right, I'm claiming all of this land for England and Elizabeth. And he calls it New Albion. So this is the first English possession in the West Coast of America. California. Californians could perhaps reflect on this. There are open arms if they want to return to the
戴在德雷克的头上。所以很明显德雷克说，好吧，我宣布这片土地归英国和伊丽莎白所有。他称之为“新阿尔比恩”。所以这是英国在北美西海岸的第一个属地。加利福尼亚人也许可以反思一下这一点。如果他们想回到英国王室的怀抱，那里有张开的双臂。
bosom of the English crown. So he's done a sort of Nick Clegg and he's gone after San Francisco. Yes. But rather like Nick Clegg, he ultimately is going to return home, though perhaps a little bit more popular. Yeah, he wants to come back. He doesn't want to hang out. I mean, he likes the Milwaukee, but he doesn't want to stay with him. He's obviously not going to go over land. Yeah. But, I mean, that means he has to go back by sea all the way down the coast of South America again, surely not. Can't do that. So what? He's going to have to sail across the Pacific, go head westwards. He's going to have to follow in Magellan's, not footsteps, but in his wash. Yeah.
所以他做了一个类似尼克·克莱格的举动，他去了旧金山。是的。但就像尼克·克莱格一样，他最终还是要回家，尽管可能更受欢迎一些。是的，他想回来。他不想待在那里。我的意思是，他喜欢米沃克人，但他不想和他们住在一起。他显然不会走陆路。是的。但是，这意味着他必须再次乘船沿着南美洲海岸一路南下，肯定不行。不能那样做。那怎么办？他必须横渡太平洋，向西航行。他必须跟随麦哲伦的，不是脚步，而是他的航迹。是的。
It's obviously very risky. You know, sailing across the Pacific is a massive ask. But Drake has prepared for it. So every Spanish ship that he has captured, he's taken charts, he's got sailing guides. And before he leaves California, which he does on the 24th of July, he stocks up with sea birds and seals. so he kind of butchers them and sorts them. So hopefully this will be enough to keep him going. I mean, but it's better than drinking your own urine, I guess.
这显然非常冒险。你知道，横渡太平洋是一个巨大的挑战。但德雷克已经为此做好了准备。所以他捕获的每一艘西班牙船，他都拿走了海图，他有航海指南。在他离开加利福尼亚之前，也就是7月24日，他储备了海鸟和海豹。所以他把它们屠宰并处理好。希望这足以让他坚持下去。我的意思是，但这总比喝自己的尿要好，我想。
So the golden hind set sail westwards from California, and it is 68 days at sea without sight of land. And then finally, on the 68th day, they reach an island called Palau, which is west of the Philippines, and they arrive there on the 30th September. And the scene is very Captain Cook. The inhabitants of Palau have never seen a European before, never seen a European ship, and they're all kind of rowing out on their canoes and things like that. They're welcoming.
所以“金鹿号”从加利福尼亚向西起航，在海上航行了68天，没有看到陆地。最后，在第68天，他们到达了一个叫帕劳的岛屿，它在菲律宾以西，他们于9月30日到达那里。场景非常像库克船长。帕劳的居民以前从未见过欧洲人，从未见过欧洲船只，他们都划着独木舟之类的东西出来。他们很欢迎。
You know, they don't kill Drake as the people of Hawaii end up killing Captain Cook. And by early November, the golden hind has reached the spice islands, which are in the east of Indonesia. And there they find the local Sultan is at war with the Portuguese. So very keen to sign Drake and the English more general. as allies and he gives Drake six tons of clothes god that's a lot of clothes no this is fabulous wealth yeah kind of just adds to the the gold and the silver and he gives a ring for queen elizabeth and in return drake says absolutely we will send a fleet of english ships to help you out against the portuguese i mean obviously that never happens but drake doesn't care because he's got the clothes so hooray he's
你知道，他们没有像夏威夷人最终杀死库克船长那样杀死德雷克。到11月初，“金鹿号”到达了位于印度尼西亚东部的香料群岛。在那里，他们发现当地的苏丹正在与葡萄牙人交战。所以非常渴望签下德雷克和英国人作为盟友，他给了德雷克六吨丁香。天哪，那是很多丁香。不，这是极大的财富。是的，这只是增加了黄金和白银的价值，他给了伊丽莎白女王一枚戒指，作为回报，德雷克说，绝对的，我们将派遣一支英国舰队来帮助你们对抗葡萄牙人。我的意思是，这显然从未发生过，但德雷克不在乎，因为他得到了丁香。所以万岁，他
up there they continue westwards and then on the 10th of january seeming disaster because the golden hind runs a ground on a reef, and it's impossible to budge. The reefs are kind of very, very scratchy. Sort of coral reefs, yeah. So Drake tries prayer first. That doesn't seem to work. And so then they try offloading the artillery. That still doesn't seem to work.
在那里，他们继续向西航行，然后在1月10日，似乎发生了灾难，因为“金鹿号”在暗礁上搁浅了，而且无法移动。暗礁非常非常粗糙。珊瑚礁之类的，是的。所以德雷克先尝试祈祷。那似乎不起作用。所以他们尝试卸下火炮。那仍然似乎不起作用。
So they then revert to prayer. And then the prayer does work because in the afternoon, the wind changes and the golden hind slips off the reef. And the only damage is a slight leak, which is very simple to repair. And so by late March, they've left jar. are behind and on the 21st of May they catch sight of Africa. And that actually is an incredible feat of navigation as well. Yeah.
所以他们随后又求助于祈祷。然后祈祷起作用了，因为下午风向变了，“金鹿号”从暗礁上滑了下来。唯一的损坏是一个轻微的泄漏，修理起来非常简单。所以到三月下旬，他们把爪哇抛在身后，在5月21日，他们看到了非洲。那实际上也是一项令人难以置信的航海壮举。是的。
You know, it's a long time at sea. And by mid-June, they're rounding the Cape of Good Hope. On the 22nd of July, they make landfall in Sierra Leone, what will become Sierra Leone, so on the west coast of Africa. And that is 9,700 miles without picking up any supplies, any provisions. Drake's crew suffer no deaths from scurvy, no deaths from dehydration. it's an incredible feat. Absolutely incredible feat.
你知道，在海上待了很长时间。到六月中旬，他们绕过了好望角。7月22日，他们在塞拉利昂登陆，也就是后来成为塞拉利昂的地方，在非洲西海岸。那是9700英里，没有补充任何补给，任何物资。德雷克的船员没有死于坏血病，没有死于脱水。这是一项令人难以置信的壮举。绝对令人难以置信的壮举。
How have they done that with no supplies? I don't, I mean... They're catching birds. They're catching fish. They're getting rainwater. It's amazing. Wow. I mean, that is impressive because, you know, without fresh fruit, I guess.
他们是怎么在没有补给的情况下做到这一点的？我不，我的意思是……他们在捕鸟。他们在捕鱼。他们在收集雨水。这太神奇了。哇。我的意思是，这令人印象深刻，因为，你知道，没有新鲜水果，我想。
Yeah, kind of comparison there, I think, between Nelson and Drake. Because Nelson also kind of understood the importance of keeping his crew healthy. Yeah, but Nelson was always getting supplies, wasn't he, from Logue from Naples and stuff. Yeah, he was. So Drake's, in many ways, I hate to say this of Nelson, but even more impressive, yeah. I mean, my guess is that local people are rowing out and giving them papaya or whatever. That's my hunch. Okay.
是的，我想纳尔逊和德雷克之间有某种比较。因为纳尔逊也理解保持船员健康的重要性。是的，但纳尔逊总是能得到补给，不是吗？从那不勒斯等地。是的，他是。所以德雷克，在许多方面，我不想对纳尔逊这么说，但甚至更令人印象深刻，是的。我的猜测是，当地人划船出来给他们木瓜之类的东西。这是我的直觉。好的。
That's great fruit knowledge, Tom. Well done. Thanks. Callum points out that they would have been eating the cloves. I mean, you can get clove-scented toothpaste. It'd be like eating silver, wouldn't it? I guess. Yeah, eat the treasure.
那是很棒的水果知识，汤姆。干得好。谢谢。卡勒姆指出他们一直在吃丁香。我的意思是，你可以买到丁香味的牙膏。那就像吃白银一样，不是吗？我想。是的，吃掉财宝。
Wow. Anyway, so by the time they reach the west coast of Africa, they're relatively. They know where they are. They can now sail up the west coast of Europe. And on the 26th September, the golden hind heads into Plymouth Sound. And as we've been saying, Drake's achievements are stupefying. The voyage has lasted 1,046 days. It was the first by an English ship, the second in history, to circumnavigate the globe. He has survived appalling weather. Drake has returned with enormous amounts of treasure, more than the entire annual revenue of Queen Elizabeth. I mean, stupefying. And he's not only plundered the Spanish, he's outsmarted them and made them look
哇。总之，当他们到达非洲西海岸时，他们相对来说。他们知道自己在哪里。他们现在可以沿着欧洲西海岸航行。9月26日，“金鹿号”驶入普利茅斯湾。正如我们一直所说的，德雷克的成就是惊人的。这次航行持续了1046天。这是第一艘环球航行的英国船只，也是历史上第二艘。他经历了可怕的天气。德雷克带回了巨额财宝，超过了伊丽莎白女王全年的总收入。我的意思是，惊人。而且他不仅掠夺了西班牙人，他还智胜了他们，让他们看起来
foolish. But all that being said, Drake has good reason to be nervous. You know, what's his reception going to be? Will the Queen really have his back? That ship that he'd been separated from by the Straits of McGillan, that will have returned to England with news of doubt his fate. So will doubt his relatives be out to get him? Surely. What about the Spanish? I mean, you know, they will doubtless have been complaining to Elizabeth. So all of this is a worry, as is the possibility that perhaps while he's been gone, Elizabeth has died or been assassinated or whatever, and maybe Mary Queen of Scots is on the throne, and she certainly won't be a Francis Drake fan. So rather than sail directly for Plymouth Harbour, Drake first of all, makes sure to hail a passing fisherman
很愚蠢。但话虽如此，德雷克有充分的理由感到紧张。你知道，他的接待会是什么样？女王真的会支持他吗？那艘在麦哲伦海峡与他失散的船，肯定已经带着对他命运的怀疑回到了英国。那么他的亲戚会来找他麻烦吗？肯定会。西班牙人呢？我的意思是，你知道，他们无疑会向伊丽莎白抱怨。所以这一切都是一种担忧，就像他离开时伊丽莎白可能已经去世或被暗杀之类的可能性一样，也许苏格兰玛丽女王在王位上，她肯定不会是弗朗西斯·德雷克的粉丝。所以德雷克没有直接驶向普利茅斯港，而是首先确保向路过的渔民打招呼
and to ask this fisherman, is the queen alive and well? And the fisherman replies to Drake's relief, yes, Queen Elizabeth still sits on the throne and is very well. And so then he continues into Plymouth. But even now he doesn't disembark because that, that the city is ravaged by plague and Drake is still nervous about the reception that he's going to get from the Queen. His wife and the mayor of Plymouth
并问这位渔民，女王还活着吗？渔民回答说，让德雷克松了一口气，是的，伊丽莎白女王仍然坐在王位上，而且非常好。所以他继续驶入普利茅斯。但即使是现在，他也没有下船，因为那个城市被瘟疫蹂躏，德雷克仍然对女王将给予他的接待感到紧张。他的妻子和普利茅斯市长
are rode out to greet him and they are able to give him a briefing. And Drake is informed that during his absence, England's strategic situation has got worse. Philip has become the king of Portugal as well as Spain, which means that he now rules
划船出来迎接他，他们能够向他通报情况。德雷克被告知，在他缺席期间，英国的战略局势恶化了。菲利普不仅成为了西班牙的国王，也成为了葡萄牙的国王，这意味着他现在统治着
an even more global empire. All Portugal's possessions are now his, as well as all those kind of possessions that Spain had won. Philip has also been backing that invasion of Ireland that we talked about in the previous episode. And most ominously of all, from Drake's point of view, Philip is demanding that Elizabeth punished Drake for, quote, his piratical acts. And so the question is, what will the queen do? And so Drake decides that he is going to stay on the golden hind, wait to find out, and hope for the best. So what will the Queen do? Is the Francis Strait going to be punished or is he going to be free to resume his life of plundering the Spanish on the high seas?
一个更加全球化的帝国。葡萄牙所有的属地现在都是他的，以及西班牙赢得的所有那些属地。菲利普也一直在支持我们在上一集中谈到的对爱尔兰的入侵。最不祥的是，从德雷克的角度来看，菲利普要求伊丽莎白惩罚德雷克，因为“他的海盗行为”。所以问题是，女王会怎么做？因此德雷克决定他将留在“金鹿号”上，等待结果，并祈祷最好的结果。那么女王会怎么做？弗朗西斯·德雷克会受到惩罚吗？还是他可以自由地恢复他在公海上掠夺西班牙人的生活？
Listen, there's only one way to find out, and that's to listen to the next episode of The Rest is History. Now, if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, have our own swashbuckling crew, then you can listen to that episode right now. If you would like to sign up to embark on our voyage around the world, around world history, then you should head to the rest is history.com because Tom, as you will know, that is the only way you can get all of the unbelievable benefits from our own Cerro Rico, from our own massive silver mine. We hand out bounty, don't we? But you only get all that bounty by signing up at the website rather than on one of the various platforms.
听着，只有一个办法可以找到答案，那就是收听下一集《历史的其余部分》。现在，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，拥有我们自己的海盗船员，那么你现在就可以收听那一集了。如果你想报名参加我们的环球航行，环绕世界历史，那么你应该前往therestisistory.com，因为汤姆，正如你所知，那是你从我们自己的塞罗里科，从我们自己的巨大银矿中获得所有难以置信的好处的唯一途径。我们分发赏金，不是吗？但你只有通过在网站上注册，而不是在各种平台之一上注册，才能获得所有这些赏金。
Dominic, I have even more exciting news because we are running a summer sale and so for a limited time, if you want to sign up to the rest of the history club, listen about the dinosaurs and a host of other supplementary benefits, then you will get an extra 20% off an annual membership using the code summer 26. And this is only valid until the 31st of August. So hurry, hurry, hurry, while stocks last. So do that. Also, I think the important thing to do is to subscribe to our free newsletter. Definitely. We've got all kinds of articles and extracts and amazing things. So basically, we've got a lot of silver and we're giving it away. We're just throwing it around, you know, willy-nilly. We want people to share it because that's the kind of people we are. And on that bombshell, we will be back next time with the further adventures of Francis Drake. So we'll see you then.
多米尼克，我有更令人兴奋的消息，因为我们正在进行夏季促销，所以如果你想在有限的时间内注册“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，听听关于恐龙和许多其他补充福利的内容，那么你将使用代码summer 26获得年度会员额外20%的折扣。这仅在8月31日之前有效。所以快点，快点，快点，售完即止。所以去做吧。另外，我认为重要的事情是订阅我们的免费时事通讯。绝对的。我们有各种各样的文章、摘录和令人惊奇的东西。所以基本上，我们有很多白银，我们正在把它送出去。我们只是随心所欲地把它扔来扔去，你知道。我们希望人们分享它，因为这就是我们这类人。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次会带着弗朗西斯·德雷克的进一步冒险回来。所以我们到时候见。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。